good morning everyone
and welcome to the house committee on
Health and Human Services and elderly
Affairs before we get into the testimony
of the day on the various bills we have
scheduled I'd like you to join me in the
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
thank you everyone
the first bill for us to consider today
is House Bill 598 and for the purposes
of introduction I would like to
recognize the prime sponsor of this bill
so uh good morning Mr chair and members
of the Health and Human Services
committee I'm representative Jess
Edwards representing Rockingham District
31 that's Auburn Candia Chester in
Deerfield I'm here today to introduce
House Bill
595 excuse me is that right 5998
relative to funding maternal mortality
reviews
this bill
came about
in my role as a vice chair of the Health
and Human Services oversight committee
last term I see representative Pearson
here today I don't know if he's
intending to speak on this but he's he's
been our chair
and it was during testimony from about
the maternal mortality process that it
became clear that they could do some
good for our our citizens if they had
some money
they just hadn't asked for it before so
what we proposed during the oversight
hearing and what this is now the
execution of that promise
was the establishment on if you look at
it from a line
nine on the first page to 27 it really
describes the the establishment of the
fund and it's got Six Bullets on the
good that they could do ranging from
data analysis to quality improvement and
birthing facilities to improving
coordination The Chronic Health Care
conditions to and I think this is a big
one in New Hampshire unfortunately the
on 21 to help individuals with substance
misuse screening treatment and Recovery
screening for mental health conditions
and then public Outreach and education
so that people understand the importance
of a good prenatal care and some of the
warning signs that they may have a
problem so so that's really the bulk of
the policy question before you
shall we establish this dedicated fund
the first sections line one through five
is simply
proforma telling the treasurer that you
know we need to have those monies
transferred
and then the rest of this is
um a finance issue that that would go to
division three
um I I will I will just head a headline
for you though for situational awareness
that it moves marriage money
to help
fund a program to help babies and moms
so we're gonna we're gonna take them the
marriage money that we're collecting
from marriage licenses and marriage
officiate licenses and we're going to
move them from domestic violence in this
bill to helping with our infant
mortality issues that's on the tune of
about 450 000 dollars
but to help
compensate for that I'd worked it out
with the chair of Criminal Justice to
increase the domestic violence fees
which were bizarrely only fifty dollars
you know it costs more to get married
than it does to you know beat somebody
um so so we're going to raise that up to
250 dollars and we're going to dedicate
those fines they were already dedicated
but this is at an increased level uh to
backfill the hole on domestic violence
there will be some concerns raised
because this is about the third term
I've discussed this that oh no if you
don't do these dedicated funds we're not
going to fund domestic violence the way
it should that's not true I I made a
promise that I would use division three
to make sure the domestic violence fund
was protected and in fact in this last
budget cycle I increased the domestic
violence the the application of General
funds by well over the inflation rate so
I'm an advocate of making sure that we
have good healthy domestic violence
programs I'd like you to focus on the
policy issue if you wouldn't mind and
trust me that I'm not going to let the
finance part of this have have problems
as this works its way through its budget
cycle so with that I I can take
questions
questions from committee members
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I'm having a little
hard time getting around the issue of
confining questions to the policy
because there is no Health policy here
because the the program is already
established the issue here is it not
true that the issue here is only the
funding piece no
no this is this is uh this establishes a
special fund for maternal mortality
review it's chartered with the six
elements that it would do none of this
is in law uh and this would would
establish that fund for the first time
so that's the policy issue shall the
legislature establish this special fund
to Pro to provide financial support to
our maternal mortality efforts and I'm
asking you to say yes to that okay and I
have a follow-up if I may Mr chair
so in choosing to do that I really want
to know why
you chose to do the smoke and mirrors of
taking from One Fund and going to
another and then replenishing that fund
why not just start with the fees in
section five and take them around to
where you wanted them to go in the first
place why do we have to do the puddle
jumping so so I take issue with a
description of it being smoke and
mirrors it's clearly in the legislation
I'm clearly here testifying what the
impact is so I I don't care to answer
that question I think it's offensive
it's not smoking mirrors it's a it's a
clear Financial issue that's not really
yes representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman and also thank you
for taking my question
given the fact that this money is not
going to help the person who's paying it
doesn't in fact become a tax because in
essence the fee is something that has to
benefit the person paying the fee so if
the person's paying the fee does benefit
from the fee I would not really taking a
tax and calling it a fee so I absolutely
love the question because it it really
juxtaposes
um
the situation that we're in now and and
let's say I I agree with the general
premise that a fee in a tax are
different and that a fee is intended to
provide a government benefit to the
people who are paying it currently the
money from marriage license is going to
domestic violence programs as though
there's a causual link
uh or a Nexus
between marriage and beating your spouse
and and and and that I think is a more
spurious
um uh uh analysis or a metaphor then
having this marriage money spent on
improving infant mortality issues I mean
you you you you would think that in most
cases one of the outcomes of marriage is
uh is children and this fund would be to
help provide for a healthier New
Hampshire environment for those children
to be born
so I so so you could still make an
argument I think that this is not really
a fee
um I think it's uh more of a fee than
the current uh status quo
it's less bad
so are you saying basically
this is really a tax and not a fee no
no I I I'd say that um uh it it it's
it's less of a tax than the current
statute and that uh to the extent that
one can rationalize that marriage
license money should go to other
programs uh I think it is more
consistent with the purpose and value of
marriage to have the money from those
marriage license fees directed towards
uh the healthy birth of children as
opposed to being directed into a
domestic violence program
most domestic violence occurs between
unmarried couples so you know it's and
this is a part of an issue I get it I've
talked about this three terms now and
and I understand that uh my my support
for the uh institution of marriage is uh
is probably a little different than many
and but this is really a policy issue do
we want to establish this dedicated fund
do we want this dedicated fund to have
those six enumerated responsibilities
that's that's what I think the primary
concern of this committee is thank you
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here my
question is to the increase in fees on
the domestic violence it seems that only
fifty dollars of a fee for a domestic
violence somebody who is found guilty of
a domestic violence offense is
incredibly low relative to the other and
that part of fees is a restitution to to
prevent other victims in the future is
is that is that understanding correct or
am I getting something wrong here
okay so so far we've had a discussion on
taxes versus fees when you we talk about
the domestic violence that's not a fee
that's a fine that's that's punishment
and so
um so that fifty dollars under current
law is already going to the domestic
violence program and in order to help
backfill the money that they may not
have because the financial fiscal note's
not complete
um
we're increasing the fine from fifty
dollars which is ridiculous to 250
dollars and and uh that was done in
coordination with the chair of Criminal
Justice he's he's a he's a co-sponsor of
the bill does that does that answer your
question follow up thank you mostly my
follow-up question is does that mean
that when there's more domestic violence
convictions there's more funding going
to the domestic violence fund and if
it's reducing it might be lower if it's
less of an issue well well sure there is
that correlation
um assuming that the criminal justice
system keeps up with uh charging and
Prosecuting domestic violence I mean
that's that's sort of a random element
in today's environment are we going to
hold people accountable for their
criminal conduct but assuming that that
remains constant yeah there would be a
direct correlation and in a way that
kind of makes sense you know if there's
more domestic violence there would be
more money going to it if there's less
there would be less but but in any case
the vast preponderance of the money is
coming from the general funding from
federal money and and you have my
Assurance that as the chairman of
division three I will do everything I
can to protect the general funds going
to fund the domestic violence program
any other questions yes
thank you Mr chairman thank you taking
my question uh so I'm I'm assuming that
you're saying that the domestic violence
fund will not in any way be harmed by
this
and the second question is the simple
one is this a non-lapsing or elapsing
fund that it's going to be going into I
think this is elapsing I think we try to
default to lapsing but I I honestly
don't know the answer to your question
it's just not in the um so I'm just
wondering if it's a laugh which one is
not which one are you asking about the
new fund I want to establish yes the new
fund
um okay I was I was confused I was
thinking we were talking about the other
programs
um that's that's a good question I I I
would not have a problem with making
this non-lapsing because relative to the
general funds uh this is a small amount
of money
um so so having this being non-lapsing I
don't think creates a financial
Eternal deaths did we have last year or
the year before we we have people from
the Department here that can provide you
the one department has signed up to
speak later okay thank you thank you
that's a good question
oh I'm sorry yes
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question so
um so this this review board already
exists
um and so what what does this do to the
Baseline I'm just trying to get a feel
for how much it actually grows what's
going in you say it's kind of scatter
shot how it's being funded now so what
does this where's the Baseline at now
and how does this impact that Baseline
the the official baseline is zero
um apparently they're not set up to to
receive any money and the board exists I
think on uh you know shoestrings and
borrowed Manpower from somewhere but but
the department is here Ms Tilly and and
I I forget Lisa's last name it starts
with an S but they they could provide
you with those details
representative Weber
I'll try mine again and I'll I'll
apologize for the inordfulness of my
so the board and the review already
exist
why is this not purely a matter for the
budget cycle and finance and Ways and
Means rather than bringing it to Health
and Human Services
well first it starts with the department
and the governor I I we the legislature
doesn't normally just step in and say
we're going to throw money at you that
we've we've not had a request in Prior
years and as we heard in HHS oversight
the lack of funding was hindering some
of the good work that they could be
doing to representative Nutter uphams
question at least the implication is
will this money get us any improvement
in our
maternal mortality rates it was
testimony in HHS oversight that it it
would be contributory that it would help
with their mission and I I don't know we
have so few babies in New Hampshire I'd
like that to be a good situation as much
as possible did I answer your question
okay I see none thank you very much
okay going forward again now after we
get past the prime sponsor in each bill
we are going to be limiting some
subsequent testimony to three minutes
uh so please be mindful of that as we
proceed uh the next person signed up to
speak on this bill is representative
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Mark Pearson I
spent six happy years in this committee
the last two is Chairman I presently
chair children and family law and I'm
happy to be a co-sponsor of this bill
America leads the world in many things
but
one area where we lag woefully behind is
in the area of the morbidity and
mortality of women who are about to give
birth or who have just given birth I
think I read we are 20th amongst first
world Nations
while we can Intuit reasons for this
bill
good solid data is much more helpful in
identifying specific issues along the
way towards
data-driven conclusions that will yield
much needed improvements
this Bill calls for getting that data
line 15.
our legislature is notorious for passing
legislation that is wise and feels good
and is left languishing for lack of
funding
this bill has some funding mechanisms in
it
I will leave the explanation and defense
of the specifics to those who crafted
the bill
I'm simply here as a fiscally
conservative and compassionate
Republican
to encourage you to enable our state
better to support women and their babies
in this area of great need that is my
testimony Mr chairman thank you
thank you representative Pearson
yes go ahead
thank you chairman McDonald
um I have a question that I'll another
question I'll save for further testimony
which is kind of a prequel to what I'm
about to ask you but that is
um you want data it sounds like you want
more information
and my curiosity is
can't we just look to some other states
as far as data acquisition goes can we
look to some other states because I I
suspect New Hampshire is not entirely
unique in this regard can we look to
other states and what they've already
done just to maybe save some money thank
you thank you representative King you
are singing one of my songs I tell
people I tell myself if you're crafting
a bill find out what other states are
doing that data will help us I think we
also need to know how we're doing here
they also signed up to speak is Elisa
servoice from the Department of Health
good morning I'm Lisa cerice bureau
chief for population health and
Community Services
within my Bureau sits the maternal and
child health section which oversees the
maternal and child health Review
Committee as well as a lot of work that
is done with this population
coming around is the 2022 annual report
of the maternal and child the maternal
mortality Review Committee that was
uh presented to the HHS legislative
oversight back in December and that's
available online as well
in
2012 RSA 13230 established the maternal
mortality review panel for New Hampshire
that Review Committee is charged to
conduct comprehensive multi-disciplinary
reviews of maternal deaths for
identifying the factors that existed at
the time of death as well as data
analysis
and de-identified then review of what
happens so that recommendations can be
made to hopefully reduce or prevent
maternal deaths moving forward in our
state
there was a question previously about
other states most states in the U.S do
have maternal mortality review
committees
here in New Hampshire ours is a
multi-disciplinary committee that is
made up of Obstetricians
family practitioners
nurses Community organizations Social
Services many of the professionals and
organizations in our state states that
touch the lives of a pregnant woman and
then postpartum
there was a question asked about the
number of deaths so between 2020 and
2021 there were 11 pregnancy Associated
deaths and when we use the word
pregnancy Associated it's pregnancy
through one year after the end of
pregnancy
and so it's important to note that maybe
while 11 seems like a small number it's
11 too many deaths of our women and
there is much larger numbers when you
think about maternal morbidity and so
those are our near misses that are
costing
our states and our programs much money
to then support and help the mom through
the process afterwards so those 11
deaths here in New Hampshire were
primarily made up of substance use
overdoses Then followed by cardiac and
[Music]
personal non-lapsing
funding that potentially this bill would
propose and I also just want to take a
minute to thank representative Edwards
for his efforts in bringing this bill
forward in hearing the concerns and the
recommendations of the committee so
thank you for that
um the proposed funding in this bill
would allow the maternal mortality
Review Committee to enhance the work
that's happening and So currently it's
Federal funding that is supporting this
work but due to the minimal funding
there's only so much that can be done
and so
the the the additional funding here is
really too too pronged so the first
would allow for additional hours of data
extraction which would allow us to learn
more about what has happened in these
deaths
and then it would allow funding for the
implementation of the recommendations so
there's currently no funding to support
the recommendations that come out of the
committee after reviewing these deaths
there there are some efforts of course
across our state looking at some of
these but nothing dedicated to this
committee's work and so most of the
deaths that are presented in the report
you'll see and as I mentioned are
related to substance use and so you'll
see a lot of those recommendations are
focused that way because that's what we
saw for deaths the past two years
um and so while this funding will
support the enhanced work it is worth
noting that there is concern of removing
the funding from the domestic violence
work over to the maternal mortality
committee
um because their work is also much
important for the safety wrapping up
though thank you
you don't have to wrap I mean are you
are you all set yeah yeah I'm happy to
take any questions questions uh
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking this question earlier testimony
um
referenced infant mortality does the
maternal mortality review board deal
with infant mortality as well or is that
a different
group
so we have two different
mortality review committees in our state
there is an infant and child fatality
Review Committee that is charged with
separate work and then there's the
maternal mortality
so this is specific to the maternal
mortality thank you
other questions
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here is
this committee focused on maternal
mortality or has the scope expanded to
maternal morbidity I understand that's
also an issue but it seems tasked
specifically to mortality in my reading
so the charge of the committee is
specific to mortality
um because the the direction is set by
the RSA and by CDC guidance for because
this is a national effort to look at
maternal mortality across the country
but there are conversations of what can
we do through our recommendations to
prevent getting to the mortality piece
which of course focuses then on the
morbidity
thank you
yes representative McLean
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so I understand how
the funding would allow you to do
um extra data analysis things of that
nature I'm just curious as to the
mechanism of of how the implementation
would occur I would assume that would be
other agencies that would be doing
implementing and not necessarily the
board so how how would that funding be
leveraged by this board I'm not quite
understanding how that would work yeah
thank you for that question my
understanding is because the oversight
of this committee sits in public health
within the maternal and child health
section that the funding would come
through the division and it would likely
be put out through contracts in our
state for the people who are doing the
work at the community level but with the
direction and scope set by the
okay I see none
they also signed up to testify is Lynn
from the nhca dsv and I'll let you
am I on now there we go good morning Mr
chairman members of the committee my
name is Lynn shallette I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire Coalition
against Domestic and Sexual Violence and
I'm joined by Pamela English our
administrative director I'm here to
speak in opposition to house bill 598. I
want to be clear we are not taking a
position on the funding for the maternal
mortality review board we do however
object to removing a stable source of
funding for domestic violence services
the domestic violence prevention program
was created by the legislature in 1981
establishing a guaranteed funding source
for these Services the Coalition where
Pam and I work is the umbrella
Organization for the 12 community-based
crisis centers in New Hampshire that
serve approximately 15 000 victims of
sexual and domestic violence every year
and one of those member programs is here
to testify as well
this program over the course of its life
has supported tens of thousands of
victims
the dvpp is made up of several funds as
you've heard today General funds being
one of those those are important funds
they have also very varied widely over
the history of this program
if we went back about 10 years pretty
consistently the general funds were
about sixty thousand dollars in the last
10 years they have varied from a low of
2 000 to a high of well over a million
another portion of this fund is the
marriage licenses that we're discussing
today
sponsor representative Edwards suggested
that the connection between marriage and
domestic violence is spurious the data
from our program shows exactly the
opposite
we collect data on the individuals that
we serve and according to Statewide data
over the last five years 27 percent of
the victims that our programs served
were in spousal relationships or
formerly spousal relationships in fact
it's the highest relationship connector
of all of the people that we serve
and and just to give you a kind of
national perspective 30 other states
utilize marriage license fees to support
domestic violence programs in New
Hampshire these fees bring in
approximately 450 000 to 500 000 a year
however what I really want to address
today is the importance of continued
stable funding for domestic violence
Services unfunded programs should never
be the reasons that we don't serve a
domestic violence victim in New
Hampshire and while we appreciate the
sponsor's commitment to funding these
life-saving programs the alternative
funding source proposed in this bill is
inadequate and unstable for two specific
reasons as you've heard the first way
this bill would change the current
funding structure is to increase the
fine imposed under Joshua's Law on
domestic violence convictions
currently Joshua's Law brings in on an
average of about 42 thousand dollars a
year ranging from a low of approximately
thirty eight thousand to a high of about
55.
unfortunately fines collected on
convicted offenders are not a stable
source of funding
the first reason for that is collecting
and redistributing those fines uh is not
a consistent practice hey if you could
start wrapping up please okay uh what we
know about the collection of these fines
from the New Hampshire courts is that
they are often paid late 40 percent of
offenders do not pay on the day of
conviction 38 percent of offenders delay
their payment usually for an average of
six months and 24 percent of offenders
never pay the other issue is that
quintupling the fine will not solve the
problem currently many offenders do not
pay and according to the Federal Reserve
more than 40 percent of the people in
the United States do not have four
hundred dollars in the bank to address
an emergency The Collection rate of
these will not improve so thank you we
encourage you to vote itl on this bill
okay thank you Ms English would you like
to testify or you hear for questions
to take questions okay questions for
these ladies
yes
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so just to clarify
um representative Edwards testified that
he would make sure that the funding Gap
would be plugged your concern then is
not for this cycle but down the road for
subsequent Cycles because it would be
tied into the general fund and that's
where your concern lies our primary
concern thank you for the question
representative I appreciate it our
primary concern is that general fund
dollars fluctuate and fines that are
assessed on convicted criminals are not
collected consistently universally due
to several factors it's difficult to
collect those fines but often offenders
don't have the money either so just
increasing the fine will not ensure a
stable source of funding whereas the
marriage license funding year after year
is at a relatively level level so our
programs can rely on those funds
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
today
um I I have a question for you about any
correlation between offenders that are
in a condition of non-payment and
reoffending in addition in in future
domestic violence situations is there a
correlation is this something that we
need to be digging in further that this
is just a canary
thank you for your question
representative recidivism rates are very
difficult to track for many reasons so
much of the pattern of abuse is often
not reported to law enforcement not
prosecuted as the sponsor noted earlier
today so it's very hard to know whether
a fine be it small or large impacts an
offenders Behavior going forward I think
what we can most hope is that we fund
prevention programs and try to stop that
behavior before it occurs follow up as a
follow-up I wasn't asking about
causation I was asking about correlation
when you look at repeat offenders is
there a correlation between repeat
offenders and non-repeed offenders and
their payment status on prior fines
thank you for the question I don't think
we know that because of the difficulty
in really collecting data on reoffensis
or recidivism I have not seen any
okay yes representative McKay
Mr chairman
tell exactly what position you're taking
on this bill are you willing to tell us
whether you support or oppose
thank you for your question
representative McKay we are not taking a
position at all on funding maternal
mortality
thank you very much
other questions yes representative
clearly these are two very important
programs and it's unfortunate that we're
um in a discussion about them competing
for funding
um
so
aside from the fact that you're saying
the fines are less
consistent and also you mentioned that
it was approximately forty thousand
dollars compared to four hundred and
do you have any ideas about what other
funding mechanism for domestic for the
domestic violence programs would leave
you feeling more assured that they will
be funded at a consistent
um
on a consistent basis I I think that um
the representative has assured us that
it will happen and I trust that he feels
that way and will do his best to do that
but we can't necessarily depend on one
person saying that um
he'll make sure
um so is there any other funding
mechanism that you would see as being
um
a consistent and stable funding
mechanisms for the domestic violence
programs thank you for the question
representative yes the marriage license
fees have been a reliable stable source
of funding very consistent year to year
to year so our only ask with this bill
is to keep that funding source intact
the general fund dollars of course are
very valuable you'll hear that from a
program this afternoon we're not here
seeking a new funding source we are
simply asking not to take this one away
thank you Mr chair and thank you as a
follow-up to that question uh would your
concerns with this bill be eliminated if
what we decided to do was eliminate
section four which is the special
part
which is what
I think you are
concerned about actually it would be
section three and four and if we took
section five and had the extra fees paid
directly into the maternal mortality
review board would that re would that
take away your concerns about this bill
thank you for the question
representative Weber I don't think it
would because to the points that some of
you raised earlier today the underlying
use of these funds should be connected
to the reason that they are collected in
the first place and they are collected
because someone has been convicted
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt of a domestic
violence crime so I believe it's
appropriate should there be a change in
the fee in the future for that to stay
in the dvpp
okay so so just to be very clear follow
up sorry
making that change would not
uh change your objection to this bill
that's correct thank you representative
other questions for these ladies
okay I'm representative Merchant thank
you Mr chairman also thank you take a
question I want to follow up on
representative Weber
right now 50 of the fine goes into the
fund
and representative Edward wants to
increase that to 250. if we only took
the 200 increase and put that into a
fund would that solve the issue as well
thank you for your question
representative Merchant I just want to
clarify are you asking if there was an
increase and it went to the maternal
mortality would that address our our
concerns correct um no again because
these can these fines are assessed on
convictions for domestic violence also I
know you're going to hear this later
from one of our member programs we don't
keep any of these dollars at the
Coalition they pass directly through to
the crisis centers and they are used for
direct reimbursement for out-of-pocket
costs that victims incur as a result of
domestic violence so if the offender
bashed a hole in someone's wall or rip
the telephone out of the wall or stole
something that is the kind of thing that
these funds are used for they're not
even used to pay the salaries at the
crisis centers these are reimbursing
tiny costs car repairs child care
a prescription that someone needs from
an injury is a result of domestic
violence
are there any other questions
seeing none
representative Leon sorry I apologize
for this follow-up I'm just curious that
seems like that would be a civil action
to go after the offender in order to pay
that restitution is that something that
is not pursued by these groups in order
to empower these women and make their
lives full
so crisis centers would not be able to
be a party related to restitution as you
know restitution happens in a criminal
case when there is a conviction courts
infrequently order restitution and it's
also very difficult to collect when it
can be collected that is wonderful but
that's a very small number of cases that
that ever happens in most most of these
cases are never in the criminal justice
system
okay seeing no other questions thank you
very much
and I'll leave copies of our written
testimony thank you Mr chairman thank
you
and the last card I have for in terms of
someone signing up to testify is from
morning good morning my name is Shawna
Foster and I'm the executive director at
New Beginnings a local crisis center
based in Laconia that serves over seven
over 600 survivors of Domestic and
Sexual Violence each year
I'm here today in opposition to House
Bill 598 and I appreciate the
opportunity to speak today
I have significant concerns about the
impact that this bill would have on our
organization's ability to meet the needs
of victims and their families served
throughout Belknap County
we see firsthand every day how important
this funding is to our program dvpp
funds are used to provide essential
Direct Services to victims of domestic
violence these include free and
confidential 24-hour support
Hospital accompaniment 24 hours a day
Court accompaniment
safe shelter for victims and their
families transitional housing supports
one-to-one peer support and support
groups for all ages
the supports offered by our Advocates
stop serious physical abuse and save
lives
it's important that we're able to
maintain a stable reliable source of
funding to be able to continue meeting
the needs of victims in our community
this bill jeopardizes that and if passed
we would not receive the same level of
funding that we currently receive under
the existing system
I'm grateful for the legislative Slater
for being so supportive of our programs
and our funding please vote no on this
bill to ensure that we can continue to
help those in need in our community I'd
be happy to answer any questions okay
thank you questions
questions from committee representative
Leon thank you Mr chairman and thank you
not only for being here but the
important work that you do and I
apologize for not thanking the previous
testify people for that as well so
important my question is regarding the
services for traumatized children the
operation of the helplines and the
training confidential Advocates are
those people that you contract with
outside of your program or is that part
of your staff and part of the duties at
New Beginnings in order to help these
people in this time of need those are
part of our regular staff thank you yes
I see no other questions so
thank you very much thank you
does anyone else wish to testify on um
if not then I am going to be closing the
public here I am hereby closing the
public hearing on House Bill 598 and I
am opening the public hearing on House
Bill 264 and accordingly we'll recognize
representative Cannon the prime sponsor
for her testimony a member of our
committee
good morning representative Cannon good
morning
Mr chair
and to my fellow
members on the Health and Human Service
and elderly Affairs committee this is my
third term on this
since 2005
there's been a law in the books to allow
transgender
people who've had a sex change to change
their gender marker on their birth
certificate
in the past two years
only 44 people
were able to change their birth record
information
most of the most of the people I know my
friends my transgender Community friends
most of them were born out of state and
for many of them it was easy to go out
of state to where they were born and
change their information
not so in for people born in the state
those that I know that are older or like
myself
or or younger
for those who don't know I'm 70 years
old
so and I knew I was a transgender person
the folks that have been born in New
Hampshire as they've gone over many of
them have given up trying to get their
birth records changed because it's in
many ways the the process is not clear
and we've even heard that there are some
justices that will grant
the gender change information
not fully understanding
the amount of information that's
required and and others won't grant that
here in New Hampshire and in many states
you can change the gender on your
you can do the same thing with the
passport
for the federal government
I wish it were that easy
to change the information on the birth
record
you have to understand you have to think
about this
your birth certificate usually sits in a
drawer you hardly ever use it possibly
when you're young or the first time you
go for a passport if you have to bring
your passport along I mean your birth
certificate along
prove where you were born and
when you were born
they don't check the gender
on the birth certificate for many of
those
in fact I don't know if the gender is
really required on any of those because
a passport for instance requires a birth
certificate to be submitted
on same thing for the initial driver's
I'm I'm bringing this piece of
legislation as I've done a couple of
times before to simplify the process
as well as for consistent with how we
to get
the information concern um
the information
required to change the gender and the
birth certificate an individual has to
get
still has to get
information from their Physicians who
are taking care of them in most cases
excuse me in most cases a transgender
person will not only have their their
personal physician they'll have a
therapist
quite possibly a psychiatrist
neural neurologist but uh
other folks that are responsible for
their care
and they and the petitioner has to get
information to submit for changing the
that's the way it currently is and
that's the way the spill rates is they
will still have to get that information
that information was needed to provide
to the court before there is no form to
fill out
that asks for that information right now
it's sort of free form
that the Physicians are requested to
essentially send a letter
that our individual can bring to court
what I would like to see is that the
current forms that are used in the Vital
Records Office
actually have a place to check off the
Box
I don't think it's been changed
since I last reviewed it but it doesn't
even include anywhere on the form
to say that the gender information is
so why is it so important to change the
information
it's simple in some cases simple simply
being able to change an m to an F or an
F to an m on this piece of paper
might save a life
especially For Youth and for young
adults
um
they might may not use this
document from what for much except for
what I've explained but from us
a personal perspective
is to have this document reflect who
they are
as well as if they've had a
court-ordered name changed to update the
birth record to reflect that
this is what I did in
2015 actually in 2016. I had my birth
record changed in Newton Massachusetts
and submitted actually I submitted a
form at the things agenda on my New
Hampshire driver's license and it had my
Physician's name and it was notarized
and I took that to Massachusetts and
they accepted that information and I was
able to change my birth record on the
spot in the Newton Massachusetts city
hall
um here in in New Hampshire Earth record
changes need to be submitted at the in
the town or city clerk's office and it
gets sent to Concord where it's entered
into the system
which is already currently done for the
especially the past two years the 44
I mentioned the suicide the suicide
rates
of young adults
the transgender Community 82 percent of
the transgender Community have
considered committing suicide
and 46 have attempted suicide I'm one of
those people
it's when I was in between my high
school years and college Years I drank
too much
and I drove while drunk and crashed a
car
two years later
I had been battling with my gender
differences
through Junior High and High School
I was a mediocre student and very
depressed
and found it very difficult I was always
also a very feminine kid and I was uh
I graduated in high school at 118 pounds
I was a very petite person
as I mentioned I did have my uh my name
changed to Stratford County
courthouse in March of 2016. I
immediately
drove to Newton Massachusetts and had my
birth record change
then it came back up to Portsmouth and
had my social security information
changed
and then I went to the DMV to change my
license
well it was that difficult
I had to get additional information to
change that info license not because I
was changing it but because I had had a
CDL before and I had to cancel the CDL
before I could get my driver's license
it wasn't until I was 69 years old
last April that I finally had my gender
surgery
it was important enough even to that
point
to get put my life on the line
um I'm trying to save some lives here
with this bill
it's as simple as that
in past years I've had other other
reasons but this is the most important
one
um our youth or a transgender youth are
one of the highest groups of to
um
students and and transgender people that
consider suicide or have attempted
suicide
I'm trying to save some life here
if we can get this through
in its simplest form it will change the
gender marker from an m to F or F to m
all right thank you representative thank
you thank you very much any any uh yes
so just to confirm the process in a
nutshell
isn't it true that what this bill does
is simply remove the necessity and all
the Hoops that go along with the court
proceeding
to change your gender marker in the
first instance
and then because of concerns we've heard
in the past about people changing their
mind or or going back and forth or
other concerns that may or may not
actually be out there it then requires
if there's a further change that change
must go to the court is that correct
that is correct thank you
representative McKay
thank you Mr chairman
would you believe
how proud I am of
you're getting up in front of us today
and telling us
this what is a painful
presentation but a fantastically
positive area of leadership
in this state so I am extremely pleased
to support you in your work and
particularly for those with mentally
mentally ill illness and suicide thank
you very much thank you representative
other questions
yes representative kovalt
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
can you elaborate a little bit more I'm
I'm concerned about this question of
having to get rid of the CDL
in order to
get the license uh as you wanted it can
you explain that in a little bit more
detail please I think it was it was more
of a timing thing I had gotten off the
road in 2015 and I still had my CDL
license and I had decided at that point
that I was retired from driving and to
stay to save as a valid CDL license I
was going to have to get a another
um
um boy it's getting old you forget these
terms I was gonna have to get go to my
my doctor and get another physical
um just for for uh see to maintain my
CDL so I decided at the time as as long
as I was changing my my
birth record my my sex identifier on my
driver's license it was time for me to
get rid of the CDL and so I I decided to
get just a regular passenger vehicle
license
and follow up so if I'm understanding
correctly then this was not a case of
anybody at the DMV or the state failing
to follow proper procedures or enforce
the lock right they were following the
problem and at the time at the time I
didn't realize that I had to uh uh
get additional information for my CDL
and the reasons why I was not renewing
the CDL thank you for clarifying that
other questions
yes representative Merchant
thank you for taking
chairman I'll stick the question so I
want to be clear you're not asking for a
line 22 to destroy the original
the original will always be retained
you're asking for it to be modified with
a subsequent
document
that's correct
um
in all this and
when I got my record changed in
Massachusetts that original document
still exists in their file
um
so I did not put that in
to this this form the current
the current
mechanism that's in place
does not even require a marginal note
and that's a big thing for the
transgender Community
what does require a marginal note on a
changing a birth record is if you have a
name changed
laughs
so the name change could potentially be
recorded on the uh on the birth
certificate but I believe in its current
form neither the name or gender
okay thank you representative palazzov
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
and this issues around identities are
very diplomatic and I would expect that
some individuals even after
um this changes they would still be a
suicidal so do you have any statistics
or do you have any expectations uh if
this bill go to effect like what would
be percentage of prevented suicides and
what would be percentage of
suicides and watchedness still happening
I I don't have any specifics I do know
that from the in talking with families
with transgender youth
um
young people between the ages of 14 and
18 who would require having a parent
sign along with them as far as the
information
as far as the information required to
change and
um
we have seen and when I talk about is
that this little thing would help
um
them recognize that the state recognizes
them
as having changed
it's also as many parents have come to
me excuse me sorry I have asthma and I
need to use my inhaler which is over
there so I come
the um the I've had parents come to me
and say how do I get this done or can I
get this done and then I have to let
them know what the process is and many
of them will follow up on it and and
bring their child into court with them
and and get things changed but it is
cumbersome on them as well they have to
go through the process and they have to
get Physicians that'll work with them to
identify that the child is currently
under their care has identified as being
the gender that they're living as for
many years and that they may be under
the help of a therapist and a
psychologist their General physician and
and
in some cases some procedures may have
been performed or in underway they may
be taking hormone blockers
for some women change from a female to
male they may have had some
um
breast reduction surgery I know of at
least one case where the young lady had
large breasts to the point where they
had breast reduction
that helped them in the process from a
medical situation that the the weight on
their chest
um what's what's affecting their uh home
stature so there are different reasons
that people have undergone surgical
procedures to move forward
okay thank you
other questions yes representative
Shapiro
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative is
under the system that we currently have
where a doctor has to write a letter
does that require
that there have been some kind of
medical procedures whether it's hormone
treatment or some kind of surgery or is
that up to the specific Court
thank you for your question
um right now it's up to the court to
make the decision on whether enough
has enough medical
or physical changes have been done to
make the change follow up follow up so
as well as being a more difficult
process for the person to complete it's
also a more subjective process where a
person might petition to have their
gender marker changed but um
not necessarily have it come to fruition
that's correct I've even heard of cases
where a The Physician that had signed
documents was requested to come with the
family to court to actually describe the
situation
okay thank you other questions
thank you representative Cannon for
coming and testifying today I I want to
let you know that I deeply respect what
you're doing coming forward I'm sure
this is very difficult for you
I do have a question uh when you and it
goes back to something uh representative
pulls off at asked about the suicides
by removing this this
bump in the road for somebody on their
license
it gives them I'm sure it gives them
some type of
um
but don't we still have a lot more to
deal with
this is just one small little factor and
that we have so much more to do with
acceptance and the lack of bullying and
things that you've experienced and
others have experienced is that true
yes
um there's a lot of work to be done
Society
has a really hard time understanding
what's going on as far as a transgender
person goes it's not something we just
decide to do it's really hard to explain
I have known since I was 13 years old
that I was different
and back in the 1960s there was no
information and I felt I was broken
I did not fit and I hoped what was going
on with me would go away
it never went away I did get married
I thought it would go away then with
physical relations
um
in a way I personally think maybe that
was a good thing at that time because I
have two wonderful daughters
and and one's a senior bioscientist
so both both my family has done well
um
I think most of my life I felt that I've
had to prove myself so I've excelled in
everything I've done
the toughest thing I have done is when I
came out and decided to run for public
office
because I was really concerned about how
I would be perceived
I will be honest I received a death
threat on my first run for the school
board in Somersworth
and sadly I'm now a gun owner
direct and protect myself so it's a very
diff it's a very difficult world for
transgender people to live in
and we have some of the especially in
the black community there's the highest
death rate of transgender people
um
so
okay thank you representative other
questions
yes
thank you chairman
um the purpose of this bill as you said
is to
remove or reduce the number of deaths in
the okay and namely suicides right and
you also mentioned that there are other
states that have already passed similar
legislation which makes it easier to
change right 27 States 27 states do you
have any
um well-documented evidence that the
number of suicides by transgenders
previous to those bills being passed in
their respective States has been reduced
since the passing of these bills do you
have any actual evidence to back that up
I don't have specifics I do know that
um
there well I mentioned 82 of our
transgender Community have considered
that was a study that was done across
the U.S and um 46 of the entire
population have considered have
actually attempted suicide
so it's a substantial number of the
entire population I don't know if
specifics in the individual states but
um
okay thank you representative other
questions
okay I see none but thank you very much
representative thank you for listening
also signed up to testify on House Bill
264 and I I'm not sure the first name so
I apologize
um Ms peacock I believe it is from the
Secretary of State and the division of
and you put information only on your
card is does that mean you don't want
questions after or
I wasn't sure what you meant by that
I'll be happy to answer questions uh so
there's just an informational so good
morning Mr chairman and honorable
committee members my name is Patricia
pietzsu I am currently the acting State
Registrar for the division of Vital
Records and the Secretary of State's
office has no position on this bill I I
prior to be coming to the Secretary of
State's office a matter of fact I was a
city clerk and I did work with
representative cannon on this bill a few
years ago with this I think she'll
remember me on that
um the only thing that I wanted to bring
into your attention that in replacing 5c
87 with this bill is that you are
removing
um
the option for somebody that does have a
certified court order that has gone
through the gender reassignment surgery
to be able to submit that so that's the
only thing we wanted to bring to your
attention they would still then be able
to still have their physician sign off
on the form that will be provided by the
division of Vital Records and everything
like that but it'll be a committed
decision as to whether or not they would
want to still be allowed to add a that
court order for somebody that may have
gone through that gender reassignment
surgery
but otherwise than that again it's your
the committee's decision as to what you
want to do is whether or not to allow
that because the court order normally
would then remove the legal name change
that was brought up before from the
marginal note whereas because in 5c
87 4 if there is a legal name change on
there the AKA would have to remain on
the birth certificate under the marginal
note
um but that's all I have before you if
you have any questions I'd be more than
happy to answer them for you okay
questions
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
today I have a question for you about
the use of birth certificates where
they're used if that's used in the
process of determinations for
incarceration or anything else I'm just
trying to understand where outside of
our normal record-keeping birth
certificates are used so birth
certificate is used for many things as
representative Canon mentioned you you
need your birth certificate for your
passport a lot of jobs now require you
to have your birth certificate children
need to birth certificate in order to
get into school for sports when it comes
time to retirement social security so
there are many other different places
where the birth certificate maybe need
to be utilized
sorry as a follow-up is that used in the
case of incarceration or is that just
looked at through other through other
metrics
as far as license I don't know what is
required as far as I'm concern
incarcerations goes I know that we have
at times receive requests from those
that are cars in in currently in prison
or maybe in the um
House of Corrections who require birth
certificate so we do receive them but
can't say how often I thank you that's
just a larger more complicated question
I just wanted to make sure we were
addressing it thank you
representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so
um we we did receive testimony if I
understood it correctly that the process
in New Hampshire is a little bit more
Byzantine than the process and maybe
some other uh States and you have to go
through a court process so when you look
at the the process in New Hampshire
versus the more streamlined and I would
say potentially lenient process in other
states
do you see any other concerns that have
been generated in these other states by
going to this more streamlined process
well Mr representative McLean thanks for
the question I've been in this position
for only two months
so I can't really speak to the other
states I know that currently the court
order is currently required for us but I
think representative Cannon had some
good testimony as to what is happening
in other states
thank you
I see no other questions thank you very
also signed up to testify is
good morning
uh you indicate you'd like four minutes
I'd prefer if you could keep it as close
good morning chair and committee my name
is representative James Rosner and I'm
here speaking as a transgender man I
came out and began my transition about
seven years ago and in that time my lack
of sex change has not hindered My Life
as a man in any way other than through
trivial legal filings and insurance
misunderstandings
I changed my name and gender marker on
my driver's license and on other
personal documents at the same time
because if you're not familiar changing
your legal identification twice in a row
is a big pain
um
so I intentionally did them all at the
same time I am not however able to
update my birth certificate with
confidence because I have not completed
a sex change or what would be generally
interpreted as gender confirmation
surgery or bottom surgery or a genital
reconstructive surgery
um
I had come to accept that having an
accurate legal birth record is just not
a right that I have as a trans person
I'm no longer able to use my birth
certificate as a secondary means of
personal identification without it
becoming an ordeal I can only imagine
how difficult that will be if when that
presents itself if I am not able to
correct that in a timely manner my
greatest concern with the current sex
change requirement for updating birth
records is that it mandates an invasive
and personal surgical experience for all
transgender people who want to be
recognized legally
especially in the wake of so much Social
fear and confusion around gender
transition exceptionally so around
gender dysphoric children I find it
disproportionately counterproductive for
the state to require that we must
undergo an intimate irreversible and
extensive surgical procedure to be
recognized correctly as a transgender
person in our documents
mandates such as this only serve to
pressure transgender individuals to
undergo gender affirming surgeries that
do not contribute to their quality of
life
because transgender happiness and
self-comfort is not contingent on going
under the knife to better replicate our
bodies to look cisgender or
non-transgender
that isn't to say that these aren't
necessary but that transition is a very
personal and specialized procedure and
um lists of happenings and changes that
each individual decides for themself
it's not a one-size-fits-all blueprint
as I stated I have been living as a man
for seven years and I knew my entire
life that I would rather live as a man
despite all of this it's my personal
decision with my body that I do not
require a reconstructive genital surgery
especially at its price of time money
pain and risk
um that is not to say that these
services are not completely necessary
for other individuals and I hope that
testimony will continue to contribute to
that understanding and knowledge but it
is counterproductive to assert that this
of all things is what constitutes my
ability to be socially and legally
and um I also wanted to add that was the
end of my testimony
um I did while we were listening to our
introduction look up some statistics on
uh transgender legislation when that is
proposed and how that affects
suicidality especially in minors
recently the Trevor Project in Texas
reported that there was a hundred and
fifty percent increase in calls from
Texas youth uh when the transgender
threat was introduced to the Texas state
house last year there are many other
links and and studies that I can send
over but I don't want to take up any
more time here okay thank you very much
questions
any questions for the representative
also signed up to speak this morning is
morning my name is Abby Maxwell I live
in Concord and I am here in support of
HB 264
my daughter is 10 years old
when she was born we thought she was a
boy she spent her toddler years
insisting to us that she was a girl
and she spent kindergarten in first
grade saying that she did not want to
exist if we kept making her be a boy
at that time my husband and I could not
even Define the word transgender
however we finally sought Medical Care
in the form of a psychologist at one of
the best children's hospitals on the
East Coast
and we learned what it means to be
transgender and how to support our child
so that she could have a happy healthy
life
we gave her dresses allowed her to
change her name in pronouns and watched
as a light came on inside our child
literally overnight
now my daughter has been living happily
in her true gender for nearly half her
life
she even has a U.S passport issued under
the Trump Administration with the
correct gender marker
yet at school she has an IEP and because
of New Hampshire's birth certificate
laws her gender is listed as male on the
very first page her teachers and vice
principal have worked hard to get this
corrected because it's inaccurate it's
an invasion of her privacy and it also
opens the door to possible bullying and
discrimination
however because of the laws the school
has been unsuccessful in making the
correction
school is not the only place where this
comes up
every time I sign my daughter up for a
day camp that requires a complete
vaccination history as many do I also
have to out her as the wrong gender
appears at the top of the page
when I check her in at the doctors or
the dentist the receptionist still sees
M rather than f
my daughter like all of us has a right
to her privacy she should not need to
explain what it means to be transgender
when she just wants to join art or music
camp
it is already difficult enough for our
family to exist in a country and state
where our daughter's right to Simply Be
herself and is constantly debated on a
public stage this small change in New
Hampshire law would harm no no one and
it would make her life in ours just a
little easier and more importantly safer
thank you for your time okay thank you
questions
any questions
also signed up to testify is Erica Perez
good morning members of the committee
my name is Eric Perez I'm from
Manchester New Hampshire
and I'm here today in support of HB 264
representing the New Hampshire youth
movement
before I saw this bill I was unaware
that in order to change your sex marker
on your birth certificate in New
Hampshire you must first according to
RSA
5c87 have undergone what's referred to
as a sex change
right now on GoFundMe there are over 500
pages of people seeking help to pay for
their top surgeries
trans people everywhere but also in our
own communities already struggle with
finding things like safe and secure
housing and job security these surgeries
that the state has made a requirement of
changing your sex marker costs thousands
of dollars and create just one more
barrier for the trans community and our
states have to jump through having
surgery doesn't make you any more or
less trans especially when it's not a
financial decision everyone can make
this bill would make it so a notarized
letter from your doctor would be enough
to start the process of changing your
gender marker and frankly I think that
should be enough
I would also like you to consider
creating an amendment to add an option
for an X gender marker to include
intersex people non-binary people and
other people who do not feel aligned
with an M or an F
so again please vote ought to pass on HB
264 and thank you for listening okay
thank you
also signed up to speak this morning is
Courtney Reed from the ACLU of New
Hampshire
is Ms Reed here
oh there she is
thank you chairman now you have three
minutes thank you chair McDonald
I've just handed handed around a copy of
my testimony as well as a copy of a
academic article relating to the mental
health benefits for Trans individuals
who have access to change the gender
markers on birth certificates and other
IDs I think that this could serve to
bolster some of the emotional testimony
um so I would just like to provide a
brief statement of support for HB 264
and encourage all members of the
committee to review the article that's
going around which I reference in my
testimony
HB 264 is a bill that allows gender
affirming corrections to individuals
birth certificates which is a crucial
part of one's gender transition and is
foundational in ensuring individuals
with historically marginalized gender
identities can navigate institutions and
legal systems which often require
consistency and documentation which
we've heard in some of the stories
earlier today
uh presently the state of New Hampshire
only allows individuals to change their
identification their gender
identification on birth certificates
with the court order and HB 264 would
reduce the burden for individuals
wishing to make this change by enabling
the change of gender markers instead
through a notarized certificate
provided by a health care provider
passing HP 264 would put New Hampshire
on track with its pure States in New
England most of which also require only
a certification from a health care
provider and would remove the present
and unnecessarily taxing process from
the courts and reduce this burden for
transgender individuals as well
I also encourage members of the
committee to consider the basic safety
and well-being of trans individuals as
it relates to this bill
when a trans person is forced to show an
ID document that doesn't match who they
are they can often face discrimination
or even violence
this has been documented by the national
transgender discrimination survey where
it was found 40 percent of respondents
with IDs that did not match their gender
identity experienced harassment
medical and mental health professionals
have long recognized the importance of
updated identity documents as a part of
gender transition research from studies
conducted in Massachusetts in Rhode
Island the one I'm passing around where
the process of changing one's gender
identity marker is relatively easy
compared to the state of New Hampshire
found that legal gender marker and name
change was associated with lower
negative emotional response to
gender-based mistreatment and improved
mental health outcomes among trans
populations
improving access to official documents
that correctly represent one's gender
identity is a matter of dignity and laws
that make the process of amending and
correcting essential identification
documents an equally burdensome for
Trans individuals only functions to
further marginalize this community
a simple change to this process by
passing HB 264 would enable Granite
Staters to better control how their
gender is expressed and for that reason
the ACLU of New Hampshire requests the
committee vote ought to pass on HB 264.
thank you questions for the from the
committee yes representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman
um we have a question about the court
process right now we've heard implied or
stated a couple times that that would
require a surgical change for the court
to issue that order I'm looking at law
here and I don't see that what what
criteria does the court use now to to
initiate that order
yeah thank you for your question from my
understanding uh
I don't believe a surgery is required
but I can get back to you on that and I
believe other individuals providing
testimony would be able to answer that
question more appropriately thank you
a follow-up is there any place in law
where it states what what criteria the
I could get back to you on that thank
you thank you other questions
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
um thank you for providing this study
I'm just looking taking a quick look at
the abstract and the methodologies it
says that it's actually evaluating it
based upon whether they've legally
changed their name on their passport or
driver's license and I'm under the
impression that we already have that in
New Hampshire and this bill is dealing
with the birth certificate which is an
important but different document could
you clarify that for me please
that's correct
um I couldn't find a study relating to
birth certificates but I think we could
classify birth certificates as being
another essential document related to
functioning in legal systems and gender
identity affirmation thank you thank you
okay seeing none thank you very much
also signed up to testify this morning
good morning
thank you Mr chair and to the committee
for the opportunity to testify today my
name is Sam Hawkins and I'm the public
policy assistant at Nami New Hampshire
the National Alliance on Mental Illness
Nami New Hampshire is a non-profit
Grassroots organization whose mission is
to improve the lives of all people
impacted by mental illness and suicide
through support education and advocacy
on behalf of Naomi New Hampshire I'm
here today to speak in support of HB
264.
there's an emerging body of research
that shows that lgbtq individuals
especially those who are transgender or
gender non-conforming are at an elevated
risk for experiencing anxiety and
depression and are more likely to
consider an attempt suicide than their
heterosexual or cisgender peers I've
passed around a study from the Trevor
Project relevant to New Hampshire lgbtq
youth ages 13 to 24
in 2022 and that showed that 39 of lgbtq
Youth in New Hampshire seriously
considered suicide last year and 10
percent attempted it Beyond Beyond New
Hampshire as you heard from
representative Cannon a 2020 study in
the Journal of interpersonal violence
found that 82 percent of transgender
individuals across the U.S and Canada
have considered suicide and 40 have
attempted it
hormone therapy and gender affirming
surgery alone can significantly decrease
the likelihood of psychological distress
but in addition trans mental health must
be addressed socially within our
communities
the journey Journal of interpersonal
violence study found that school
belonging internalized stigma and
emotional familial neglect made a
significant contribution to suicidality
for transgender individuals based on
this data we believe that access to
Identity affirming spaces is one of the
most significant ways we can promote
trans well-being
you can see in that uh Trevor Trevor
Project report that open representation
and a welcoming environment have been
identified as qualities that make a
space affirming for lgbtq youth in New
Hampshire these spaces are few and far
between as evidenced by the fact that
only 18 percent of lgbtq Youth believe
the community to be quote very accepting
by allowing for amendments to birth
records more easily this bill would
would take an important step in making
New Hampshire at large a supportive
environment for transgender individuals
better enabling them to obtain an
affirmative legal recognition of their
identity from the state we believe that
this and similar efforts will help to
improve the mental well-being of
transgender individuals and decrease the
prevalence of anxiety depression and
suicide within the community for these
reasons we urge you to vote ought pass
for HB 264.
okay thank you our questions
does anyone have any questions of this
individual
yes representative palazzov thank you Mr
chairs thank you for taking my question
uh I want to ask you about page six uh
so there is a graph that shows
that for about five year period from age
13 to 17
comparing to about seven years from
18 to 24
and a short that period has actually
like legit representation of 60 percent
so does this graph means that
issues with transgender for some reason
are happening twice as often
as they will
in a little bit all the kids
I'm sorry could you restart your
question
so so there is a graph called h of lgbtq
use
and
it says that
use from 13 to 17
has
60 percent of
uh okay uh I'm withdrawing my question
no okay thank you
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
and taking the question just looking at
these different issues like School
belonging the internalized stigma are
you do you believe that a change in
these documents will change access to
different spaces or is this simply just
more of a welcoming accepting atmosphere
in your view
thank you for your question I believe
it's both I believe better enabling
people within the state to uh having the
state on their side
um in in getting these documents uh and
better enabling them
would give a community sense of of
belonging and acceptance within their
identity we have also heard testimony
that there are situations where you're
required to present a document uh and
there would there are safety concerns
for transgender individuals uh that if
their identity is not represented in
those documents they could be exposed to
violence so I think it's
thank you
okay I see none so thank you very much
also signed up to testify this morning
good morning everyone my name is Bill
Blum I currently live in Atkinson New
Hampshire I am a transgender non-binary
individual
my journey started at a young age when I
was a teenager I realized I was the
quilt Lady Gaga Born This Way
I was not living a genuine life
at the time I was afraid to tell my
story I lived in an unsupported area
and just kept quiet
I got married moved to Portsmouth New
Hampshire really started coming out of
my shell if you will really started
exploring
that led to the timeline in May of 2022
I walked into the DMV in Dover and
changed my gender to non-binary that
when I renew my license
in September of 2022 I was fired from my
job without cause there were no
supporting paperwork they simply
eliminated my position
in January of 2023
on the first Monday of last month I
moved out of my home
and in February
this month in less than two weeks I am
starting the mediation process to go
through a divorce
why am I telling you this story
I'm telling you the story to tell you
the story about transgendered
individuals
being transgendered yes is a noun
as a definition but it to me it's a verb
it's an action that I am taking I am on
a journey
where where does that Journey end I'm
not sure does that Journey end going all
the way to the female side of things
does that Journey end going to
getting onto hormones does that jury end
with sexual reassignment surgery
that last option is not applicable to me
or available to me right now because I
am also still unemployed
I
in the professional world I've used to
document I onboarded people at for a job
I hired over 50 people
thus processed i-9s you simply needed a
driver's license and a passport if you
didn't have that birth certificate
worked too
the state of New Hampshire recognizes
that there is
its ability to change your driver's
license is pretty cut and dry the
ability to change your passport is not
the federal government that's pretty cut
and dry
um
as a data person I find it challenging
that all of the documentation
is not in the same regards as far as the
process
if I want to end my transition by fully
having all my paperwork reflect my true
gender
I I don't I don't feel that there should
be any roadblocks financially or
otherwise that will get in the way
speak about the question about
mental health issues within the
transgender community
um yes this bill might not prevent all
suicides
um if
if we simply do nothing
we're not going to prevent anything
but if we make this change
this might make just one person
complete and whole
because I truly believe
in living a whole and truthful and
genuine life
and at what cost to me
doesn't matter at this point I've
already lost a lot
thank you for your time okay thank you
are you taking questions or are you all
set
also signed up to testify this morning
is Chris urchell I'm the lgbtq legal
who's an LG lgbtq legal Advocate and
Defender
thank you chair um my name is Chris
urchil I'm an attorney at glbtq legal
Advocates and Defenders I'm a New
Hampshire licensed attorney I work in
Boston mostly but I do a lot of work
here in New Hampshire including
legislative work and litigation and I've
assisted people in obtaining orders to
correct their birth certificates in New
Hampshire and I'm here in support of the
bill
um so there's a lot of confusion about
the process that currently exists and I
think you've heard some of that today I
want to be clear that what is proposed
in the bill is not a change in the
standard of what's required to obtain a
new birth certificate all that's changed
there's a all that's changing if this
bill becomes law is a change to the
process it's more efficient and it's
less wasteful
um just to say that I have never heard
of a person being able to obtain one of
these court orders without hiring a
lawyer I've never heard I mean and of
course you know every time you go to the
court it requires uh you know
administrative costs with the court
filing a petition
Etc asking a judge to take time out of
that judge's day to make an assessment
of something that the judge typically
isn't really equipped to assess anyway
so of course the judge is relying on
what the doctors say and um which is
which is what the bill would do and so
it's just a it's just an administrative
nightmare that doesn't have to happen to
go to records used resources Etc to
obtain this petition and it's expensive
also it creates a lot of problems for
people especially people who are born in
other states but need to obtain I'm
sorry born in New Hampshire but live in
other states and need to obtain a court
order from their home where the court is
like well we don't have that requirement
in our in our state so we don't know how
to when we don't know what we're
supposed to do and so it creates yet
another set of obstacles whereas if
there are administrative process in New
Hampshire that person wouldn't have to
go to their home State's court system to
try to get an order to deal with it
um I um want to speak to something that
rep Leon Leon has asked about
um about what birth certificates mean in
terms of access to sex separated
facilities in different and programs and
different contexts and um no New
Hampshire uh state government related uh
programmer activity relies exclusively
on birth certificates to determine
placement for and that's true the New
Hampshire inner Scholastic Athletics
Association does not even mention birth
certificates in its standards and the
doc would probably view a birth
certificate as strong evidence of where
someone should be placed but there is
absolutely no place where anyone relies
exclusively on what is um on what is on
a birth certificate or a driver's
license for that matter
um on the other hand uh private
facilities private institutions have the
right to to make their own
determinations about how they would
divide people into sex categories based
on documentation so that I hope that
answers that question the language
that's in the current statute is
outdated and it leads to confusion as
you've heard today I don't think any
judge in New Hampshire today in the in
the probate courts requires
um requires any kind of surgical
procedure or even proof of any other
medical procedure or treatment instead
they require a letter from a doctor that
says that somebody has completed
transition to the gender that they're CL
you know asking to be identified as and
so
um and so
um fortunately judges are consistent in
New Hampshire judges are great in New
Hampshire as you probably already know
um the problem the problem is that
there's a lot of confusion that people
don't necessarily understand what the
standard is and then even to go and
access that standard you got to hire a
lawyer you got to pay for to file a
petition and equity in the in the court
it is just um it's just very taxing a
lot of people don't even know it could
begin wrapping up sir
sure okay so the one thing that I want
to
um also know is that the fiscal note
um I
um I I it's for the fiscal note speaks
to a process that already exists people
can change their birth records
um through the court order system I'm
not quite sure what it is I don't want
to question what Vital Records is asking
for on the fiscal note but I would ask
that if they are updating their software
um I think that it would be prudent for
them to also accommodate other uh other
markers besides mnf and I'm happy to
take questions thank you
question just representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman thank you for your
testimony I have two questions
um I'm frustrated by that you would need
an attorney for this but what is the
cost to an individual to go through this
process and secondarily what's the time
frame
yeah that's a good question so um I
believe and I you know you can't quote
me on this I believe that the full cost
to file petition and Equity is somewhere
around three hundred dollars
um the cost to file a name change
petition is much less and judges will
typically allow you if you're in the
know they'll allow you to you know tack
on emotion onto that petition without
filing a whole new petition so the cost
could be relatively low you can also get
indigency waivers if you can't afford to
pay the cost but again you have to know
that that's an option available to you
and many attorneys will do this work for
free other attorneys will do this work
for a fee and that varies from from
person to person the time
um gosh if everything goes really really
smoothly I think you can get get the
whole thing done in a in about a month
um but that but that's you know I've
seen it take many months and multiple
Court visits because uh you know someone
will come to court with having a letter
where where the wording is unclear to
the judge and so the judge says can you
ask your doctor to get a more direct
letter uh and then you go and you get it
and then you know that just adds another
month to the whole process so that's
typically what I see does that answer
your question thank you
other questions
I represented a merchant
thank you Mr chairman also thank you for
taking my question
so
a citizen of New Hampshire
who was born in another state because
this came up with the Department of
Corrections DLC so if I was born in Mass
but now reside in New Hampshire become
incarcerated
there's nothing to prevent me from going
back to mass with my birth certificate
can be changed
this is only talking about people born
so yeah in other words if I'm
help me understand you go back to the
state in which you were born to change
your birth certificate correct not the
state in which you reside
well right it's a vital records
department typically in a state that
issues a birth certificate and there
though they would allow you to you know
be where you go to change it sure
follow-up sure so what I'm trying to
understand is if I was born in the state
of Massachusetts
but I reside in New Hampshire
I can go back to mass and change my
birth certificate using the form within
Mass
so therefore if I'm incarcerated
going back to the DLC
it's going to go back to the birth
certificate that they have in
Massachusetts not how I stand within New
Hampshire
so just to clarify if I understand your
question correctly a person who is
formerly incarcerated in New Hampshire
can get a birth certificate without
going through any court process in
Massachusetts that changes the gender
marker on that birth certificate as long
as they're born in Massachusetts and
that's true that's true regardless of
this bill of course but yes it's true um
to change your name though
um on a birth certificate or to get a
legal name change in Massachusetts or in
New Hampshire you will still need to go
through a court process that evaluates
for things to make sure there's no
improper purpose
um you know for for changing your name
so that a transgender person who is
formerly incarcerated will have to
demonstrate that no I'm not doing this
because I want to hide my identity I'm
doing this because I uh you know want to
reflect who I am
yes
thank you Mr chair I have two quick
questions with your Indulgence sure
thank you
um so my first question
um you you clarified that this is a
matter of process not the standard and I
think it might make sense to have
harmonized documents I'm just kind of
wondering from a history perspective why
in 2005 when we created this initial
process was the birth certificate
differentiated from these other
documents in terms of having to go
through the court process why was that
kind of set apart that's that's a really
good question
um unfortunately I can only speculate
because I've only been doing this work
for four years and not you know not not
20 years um but um my understanding is
that Vital Records departments are often
really hesitant to adopt any kind of
changes to birth records because of the
importance that those administrations
place on what you know what what a
record actually represents today I think
that there's a much better understanding
among Vital Records departments across
the country and I don't mean to speak
for Vital Records here but that day
databases are actually where information
is stored and that you know and this
this bill does nothing to change you
know how vital records stores
information and that a piece of paper is
really a piece of documentation that
someone uses to navigate tricky
situations in life does that answer your
question yes thank you and my and my
second question just quickly
unfortunately the lady from the
Secretary of State's office had only
been here two months so I'm just trying
to understand it seems like a lot of
unders other states have gone to this
more streamlined process and I'm just
trying to get a feel it hasn't been a
smooth process or have there been any
observed
consequences from that that might want
to be explored yeah so there's one
consequence which I kind of alluded to
earlier which is that um when you reside
in Massachusetts right now but you were
born in New Hampshire trying to convince
the Massachusetts courts that they have
to issue a court order when they're they
don't see these on a with any regularity
is really is really
um perplexing for them and you have to
like really go in and convince a judge
that it's so that's one downside that
can arise from it you know
um uh and you know so if someone say
Ohio Ohio requires court orders if
somebody was born in Ohio but lives in
New Hampshire the courts after you if
the law were to change the courts might
be like oh we don't know if we can do
this and then you know it might be a
little bit extra work to try to convince
the judge that you know the judge does
in fact have power to issue this order
for the Ohio Vital Records that's what I
see as the the major downside
and thank you representative Leon um
thank you this is actually just a quick
question could you email me your
testimony you ran out of copies and I
would love to have one oh yeah I have an
extra copy for you if you're the only
one who doesn't have it and um also I
did email it this morning so okay okay
is that okay sure any other questions
see no other questions thank you very
much
the final a person who signed up to
testify this morning is Lynn's jackows
from a 603 equity
Lynn Kaus and I live I live in Dover I
am a founder of 603 equality which is
pursuing non-profit status as a
Statewide lgbtq plus organization I am
non-binary and use they them pronouns
and I strongly support HB 254.
as was mentioned birth certificates
serve as proof of an individual's age
citizenship status and identity and are
often necessary to obtain a social
security number apply for a passport
enroll in schools get a driver's license
and apply for other benefits including
health insurance
being forced to show a birth certificate
that outs a person as trans can be a
barrier to all those opportunities it
can trigger dysphoria the significant
distress caused by misalignment of a
trans person's gender and how that
person is seen or treated in some cases
being forced to reveal a trans identity
can open up people to discrimination or
violence I've recently spoken to a
Health Market connect Navigator who may
have emailed you testimony who
specifically helps lgbtq people get
health insurance through the exchange
Medicare or Medicaid who really hates it
she has to ask trans people for the
gender marker on their birth certificate
and open themselves up that way she sees
the fear and discomfort in their eyes
even though of course she's going to
help them no matter what
like everyone trans people face many
different factors that impact our mental
health we may not be able to arrive at
an exact percentage of trans-suicides
averted if this bill were to pass but
it's easy to see how this gender
affirmation is one factor that will
benefit trans people's mental health and
well-being
I'm currently as Chris Herschel
explained the process can be really time
consuming involving taking time off work
and even more time if someone for
example files a name change petition
before the gender marker petition
causing the name change petition to be
reopened
and please support streamlining this
process and extend dignity and respect
to transgender people by voting ought to
pass on HB
254. thank you 264 actually 264. even
better we know what you mean okay thank
you uh any questions yes representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um so as a person who identifies as they
them a non-binary what does this look
like for you then so I would like to see
a bill that allows um people to update a
birth certificate to an ex at some point
I understand you know the intention was
to pass a more binary a bill first
um or I updated my gender marker on my
driver's license when that became
possible in 2019 so I have an X gender
marker on my driver's license I do not
have an X gender marker on my birth
certificate since that's not possible
but I hope that for some day for uh you
know it was really affirming for me to
have a document that shows my gender as
I understand it and
um many people would like to do the same
with birth certificates and make acts a
possibility on a birth certificate so I
would like to see a bill maybe next year
okay all set
did you want to follow up yeah you can
follow up happy to
thank you uh well yeah it's just so
if if this goes through are we just in
next year doing this again to extend
what things are we want our birth
certificates to
what we what we would be able to do with
our birth birth certificates and
and to what extent can can people change
other things
besides sex on their birth certificates
like is that coming
um I don't I've never heard anybody you
know make a case for changing anything
other than a gender marker on a birth
certificate so I'm not sure or what else
um
would be involved but I would I would
definitely like to I don't necessarily
feel a personal need myself to change my
gender marker on my birth certificate
but I definitely want that opportunity
for other people that would feel
affirmed by that
okay thank you
any other questions
okay I see none thank you very much
thank you
I know of no one else uh who has signed
up to testify is there anyone here who
does wish to testify on HB 264.
seeing none I am going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 264 and
open the public hearing on House Bill
566 and represent the prime sponsor
foreign
good morning
good morning Mr chairman I'd like to
thank you and members of the committee
for uh
for this opportunity to speak with you
uh my name is Nick jamana I'm a
representative from Keen Cheshire one
I've passed around on one side a copy a
written copy of my testimony and on the
other side a letter uh to the committee
that was written by a child care
provider in my district who was not able
to uh be here today
I'm here to speak in favor of five six
um and again I thank you for hearing my
testimony the purpose of the bill as you
can see is to create a child care
Workforce Development Fund to administer
signing and retention bonuses to child
care workers in New Hampshire
we are all well aware of the dramatic
shortage of child care workers in the
state with well-documented consequences
for the economic well-being of Granite
State families and communities
Governor sununu has listed addressing
this shortage as one of his top
priorities for this biennium and speaker
Packard as we know has created the
special house committee to explore
productive bipartisan Solutions
when we talk about the issues facing our
state around child care we talk about
affordability and accessibility
all too often however these two
desirables are at odds with each other
achieving the goal of affordability
requires that we keep the cost of child
care down ideally at seven percent of a
family's income or less
the way this is usually achieved is by
paying low wages to the women and men
who deliver this vital service
in my region of the state
the average preschool educator enters
the field making 13.51 an hour and an
experienced Early Childhood educator
makes on average
1751 an hour this works out to twenty
eight thousand dollars a year and just
over thirty six thousand dollars a year
respectively in a state where the
average cost of living is around fifty
two thousand dollars as of December 2021
no doubt considerably higher now
to give you a more personal example my
wife has been working in the field as an
early childhood educator for more than
25 years and she has two college degrees
an Associates in early childhood
development and a bachelor's in
developmental psychology she recently
became a co-director of Accenture in
Brattleboro and for the first time in
her career she is making just over forty
thousand dollars
25 years of working in the profession
with two college degrees and she's still
earning less than ten thousand dollars a
year than the average cost of living in
this state
our 19 year old son who has taken time
off from college to learn business from
the inside is currently the manager of
the Jersey Mike's restaurant in
Manchester I highly recommend it and
last year he made almost twice as much
as his mother
we certainly don't begrudge him that pay
frankly I'm really happy he can pay his
own bills
he works extremely hard and has proven
proven himself to be immensely valuable
to his employers but what does this say
about how much we value the people who
help nurture our children and keep them
safe every day the people who Comfort
them when we cannot and prepare them for
the academic and emotional challenges
over the early school years
as important what does this mean for the
future economic Vitality of New
Hampshire families and communities
as you will read in the online testimony
and hear from in-person testimony the
child care Workforce shortage in our
state has a serious economic impact
many Granite Staters the overwhelming
majority of whom are women have either
involuntarily left the workforce to take
care of children because of the lack of
accessible affordable child care options
or are forced to work fewer hours than
they would like
the research done for SP 446 from the
last session
of the legislature cites the New
Hampshire economic and labor market in
for information Bureau estimates that a
1.3 percent increase in Workforce
participation by women
between the ages of 25 and 54 made
possible by an increase in available
availability of child care would yield
an additional one billion dollars for
New Hampshire's GDP
in early February 2021 the national
Center for Children in poverty
identified the lack of affordable and
accessible child care as one of the
central constraints of the development
of New Hampshire's Workforce coming out
of the economic downturn associated with
the covid-19 pandemic
and just last month the business and
industry Association wrote that one of
the most pressing problems impeding
businesses ability to recruit and retain
a Workforce is the lack of accessible
and affordable child care without access
to quality affordable child care for
their workers businesses are unable to
fill critical vacancies which limits
opportunities for growth and stifles
their potential for economic success
this is not a partisan issue as we all
know across the country and here in New
Hampshire we have people on both sides
of the aisle working together to find
Solutions
at least six other states with
Democratic and Republican legislators
legislatures and governors have signing
and retention bonuses for child care
workers including Alabama Connecticut
Illinois Iowa Kansas and New Jersey
here in New Hampshire we have
implemented signing retention bonuses
for critically important state
government jobs
why would we not do the same for child
care workers who are essential to the
financial well-being and future of our
families and communities
building this vital Workforce means
compensating the workers and treating
them like the professionals they are and
HB 566 provides One path for moving in
that direction or in the direction of a
productive public-private partnership
without increasing the financial burden
on families
thank you for your time and
consideration and I'm happy to answer
any questions thank you representative
on questions
uh representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I'm I'm curious
um do you have data about uh the
turnover rate for employees and you've
you've specified between child care
worker and child care educator I'm
impressed your wife stayed in the field
that long but what's the turnover rate
because that'll have a huge effect on
this bonus structure here
uh I do not have that information I we
have some uh providers here today who
will give you uh some I think good
concrete answers to that question
thank you all set representative McLean
thank you Mr chair
um and thank you for taking my question
you know while I agree that child care
issues is very important and certainly
increasing the workforce participation
would be huge just looking at how this
is structured once you're into it it
looks like you're giving a three
thousand dollar bonus every fifth year
and so I'm just wondering how that was
arrived at because I really question its
ability to really do what it's promising
to do
um in terms of being able to retain
someone based on what you're describing
about your wife
three thousand bucks every five years is
not something that would kind of Turn Me
On a lot you know what I'm saying so
your thoughts yes thank you I very much
appreciate the the question uh and uh I
certainly would like to see it uh be
significantly higher uh in terms of the
bonus structure there are also uh some
other uh there's other legislation uh
that would make bonuses uh annual and
would amount over that five-year period
to to a larger amount so I agree that
there are uh this number could be higher
and there's a different way to structure
it the reason why I structured it to try
to answer your question uh the reason
why I structured it the way I did had to
do largely with again thinking about
personal experience and if over that
time at six months and then three years
and five years and every five years if
my wife had received twenty five hundred
or three thousand dollars that's money
that our family could have used for
family vacation it's money we could have
used to pre-buy oil for example for the
winter so that was my thinking behind
creating this particular structure I
think there are lots of ways to do it
but to answer your question as I crafted
this legislation that was my thinking
about spacing it out over uh
three years to five years as I said
there are other ways to do it making it
annually or quarterly for example
thank you very much thank you
thank you Mr chairman and those thank
you for taking the question
I
I totally understand where you're coming
from with Workforce participation it's
critical based upon what you just said
here in your testimony a 1.3 percent
increase uh the women part of the
workforce would increase the GDP of the
state by one billion dollars per year
why come to the state and ask where that
assistance why would not the business
Community itself step to the plate I
mean it's in their best interest
to support this cause why not reach out
to the business community and having
them
solve some of the problems versus coming
to the state
so I will um unfortunately oh no
fortunately my my co-sponsor is somebody
from the business Community Senator
Fenton I think he would be someone who
would be good to speak to that issue my
question in response to your question is
by business Community do you mean the
child care businesses themselves or do
you mean uh
what could you clarify the question for
me
it's not the child care industry itself
it's the ones that use the workforce the
child care industry would support
um so if you're looking at greater
participation from the workforce I would
assume
the clarification here that what you're
asking for is to have more people in the
workforce so the economy can become more
robust not so much specifically with
child care but the economy overall
thank you for the clarification uh
well I certainly think that that
businesses in our community should be
willing to contribute more for exactly
the reason you point out I don't believe
that that provides any consistency over
the middle or long term right there
there are businesses who may think we
don't have that many people working for
us for example who need child care uh
but also smaller businesses who may have
may not have those needs who may think
it's a good idea but may not feel
financially incentivized to help out in
a case like this and then also as I said
over time if a business decides to
contribute now or contribute three years
from now that doesn't mean that they're
going to be willing to contribute five
or ten years from now so having it
structured this way provides a guarantee
of consistency over time that the fund
will exist whereas as I said I like your
idea but I don't believe that it
provides that same stability
representative Weber did you have your
I was wondering your thoughts
um on
the uh trade-off of doing it this way
versus perhaps something like
restructuring our minimum wage here in
New Hampshire and did you give thought
to that
thank you representative Weber thank you
for the question I I think that both of
those things can and should be done
right as a another representative
pointed out right this is not a Panacea
this is not a silver bullet this is not
going to raise wages to the levels that
they need to be at in order to provide a
long-term solution to this problem so I
think both of those things need to be
done I don't think they uh need to be
done they're not mutually exclusive it's
not that we do one or the other I
believe they both need to be done thank
you thank you representative Leon thank
you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for presenting this bill
um looking at your testimony you spoke
to how for a state government jobs we
offer the Recruitment and Retention
bonuses and you were speaking about
offering that same benefit here in
private Child Care businesses you've
also spoken to increasing that amount
increasing the wages I'm just curious if
this is moving towards more of a public
partner public-private Partnership of
looking at basically extending the the
public schools down to Early Education
or looking at a fully public model I'm
just trying to understand where you're
headed here thank you
thank you very much and where I'm headed
is adequate compensation for the workers
in this field ultimately and I do think
that that has to take the form of some
kind of public-private partnership in
fact when our committee I'm on
environment agriculture but when we had
uh coffee with the governor a few weeks
ago I was talking to governor sununu and
that's exactly the phrasing that he used
when he was talking about how he
envisioned us going forward being able
to help build this Workforce is we have
to find a way to have a public private
partnership the the
idea of for example having our Public
Schools extend down right so if we had
something like a universal preschool
that got folded in at age three into our
into our into our public school system
the problem with that and I think our
our providers here could speak to it
more eloquently than I can is that's
going to kill child care
for younger children that's the that's
the most expensive Child Care uh and so
if we were to fold three and up into our
current system of public education it
would absolutely my understanding could
perhaps speak to that more uh it
destroys the private business model of
okay
thank you representative Shapiro thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking
the question are you aware that uh
a single parent with two children who is
starting off working in daycare and
making I think you said twenty eight
thousand dollars would be eligible to
receive Medicaid benefits for their
children and aren't we kind of passing
on other costs to the state by paying
our um
our child care teachers so little
uh I had not thought of that but as as
you pointed out yes absolutely and and I
think your point is very well taken
right that there are uh added costs to
this already for the State uh that I
haven't addressed in the bill but that
you addressed very well there thank you
okay I see none thank you very much
also signed up to speak this morning is
thank you Mr chair and ladies and
gentlemen the committee for the record I
am Senator Donovan Fenton I represent
district 10 which is a lot of town so
it's mostly Cheshire county and uh
Peterborough I have no formal written
testimony I'm actually going to hang up
my hat as a legislator today and just
talk about my experiences I have a
four-year-old and a two-year-old and my
two-year-old was on a 16-month wait list
for child care I'm also a business owner
and when I go out to hire prospective
employees I can't hire employees because
they can't find Child Care here in New
Hampshire and I'm in Keene so I sit on
that border right between Vermont and
Massachusetts and I try to attract them
and I just can't you know the barriers
for child care for housing whole
different story are are real
um and I'm dealing with that daily and
that that's truly really all I have to
say if you guys have any questions for
me uh representative said I was a
business leader but I'm not sure about
that but I'm happy to take any questions
about a public-private partnership thank
you Senator any questions for the
senator
I thought you're gonna let me off easy
go ahead
yes go ahead thank you chairman
I've seen articles and things in the
past where I don't know if it's
necessarily New Hampshire specific but
um let's say you want to have a little
daycare in your home that there are
regulations that require you have like
ten thousand dollar stoves and and and
and you know your air quality has to be
specifically perfect and there has to be
you know rubber on everything to prevent
somebody getting injured and there's
there's all these regulations and stuff
um can you address that is there is
there a sort of um uh cost that is
burdening people from getting into Child
Care work because it seems to me like
you want to get into Child Care work and
you're like oh sorry I have to retrofit
my house for fifteen thousand dollars
just before I'm allowed to even like do
that so that could be a serious barrier
right there you know um maybe we can
move in that direction instead what are
your thoughts about that thank you thank
you representative for the question I
think um let's twofold no I think what
you're addressing is starting your own
daycare business versus we're trying to
attract Educators to the field uh
because there's just there's no
accessible and there's no affordable
child care I think that is an option I
think another option would be uh
loosening barriers to have uh day care
centers in businesses as well the
problem is we have to do something
because it is a problem and you know a
strong economy is based on a strong
Child Care Workforce and we do not have
that and it's gonna it's really gonna
hurt us in the future but I do think
that's a good point you brought up
representative
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you senator for
coming over here congratulations it was
great to serve with you on those
committees last year my question is
about how we're having this committee
that's looking at child care and looking
at the overall question and as a
business owner I just want to ask you
how much these subsidies where the
fiscal note came in I think it was three
or four million dollars a year how these
subsidies to just go a short distance to
slightly alleviate the problem are going
to make a meaningful impact as opposed
to looking at those larger structural
issues about being able to bring in a
child care center into your office maybe
some of the downtime for your employees
providing some of that coverage for
their co-workers time how much do we
need to reimagine this and is this
subsidy just a Band-Aid
thank you for the question
representative I don't believe I've seen
the fiscal note yet for this bill so I'm
not sure if that's what you're referring
to I'm not sure what it is
um that being said uh you know a
Band-Aid is better than a wound right
now in my opinion because we have
nothing uh you know like I said my child
was waiting for 11 months up to and it's
uh you know I'm not the only person
feeling this I'm sure you will have uh
kids or grandkids that are in the same
boat I'm lucky I live near my uh my mom
and we dump our kids on her all the time
because we can't find a babysitter and
sometimes uh the child care center
closes at four whereas I work till five
or I'm here a little late depending on
how late committee goes so I think uh
any options right now are on the table
they also signed up to testify is Donna
I'm new with this
my name is Donna hasher I own the
learning path Child Care Center
and thank you for meeting with us today
the business of child care is an
important one
I say it all the time we are a
legitimate business
our monthly costs
are over you know they're millions of
dollars a year
dollars spent at local businesses we pay
federal state and local taxes and we
employ thousands of local residents
we do not get refunds or discounts for
any of these expenses but our annual
income compared to our annual expenses
is skewed
I established the learning path in 1999
up until recently I owned two large
centers employing 45 teachers
I sold my Dairy Center in December but I
still own my Salem Center I have 23
teachers employed
these 23 New Hampshire residents who I
am responsible to keep employed I need
to offer benefits and increase salaries
for the learning path to run effectively
and to reduce staff over time and
burnout I've been advertising for two
new teachers
because we are not in industry
that can function without a full staff
on a daily basis
centers of force to close classrooms
because of our low staff
and in turn this leaves families
without Dependable Child Care like you
just heard the gentleman here
help is needed any help will do a
Band-Aid is better than a wound
and we need it soon
there is an unprecedented Staffing
crisis within the child care industry
and I've never seen this before
please let's work together we could use
your support
we are the workforce behind the
workforce
thank you for your attention
okay handle
here we go go ahead representative King
thank you chairman McDonald thank you
for coming today
um so you've got business Acumen it
sounds like
um You probably balance a budget and
checkbook and these sorts of things
um I don't know if you would be able to
answer this or not but let's say you did
get like a three thousand dollar check
from the state of New Hampshire
um do you think you would likely have to
pay federal income taxes on that would
you end up spending like 30 percent of
that just to give to the IRS and and if
so
um do you think it might not be better
for you to receive more of a like a tax
rebate in the in the like so for example
let's say you're paying I'm just making
up numbers here ten thousand dollars a
year in property taxes what if you had
to pay three thousand dollars Less in
property taxes that would be right that
that's still three thousand more dollars
you have in your pocket plus you're not
having to give a third of that to the
federal government right so maybe we
could how do you feel about instead of
the money going from taxpayers to the
state of New Hampshire and then to your
pocket and then to the IRS what about
just less money you have to pay the
state New Hampshire what do you think
thank you well that's definitely another
good option
um the responsibility of the the child
care centers
get that tax credit
go to staff they would have to be
responsible owner to make sure that that
credit goes directly to the staff
thank you other questions yeah
representative McLean thank you Mr chair
so of the 23 workers
um that you have in Salem and you're
right on the border with Massachusetts
um
what what are what what is your
retention like how long have you had
these 23 uh people and
what would the impact of this bill have
on the retention of those 23 folks
um I opened the Salem School in 2011. my
director has been with me ever since
um and then I have teachers that joined
us right away and are still employed and
I have teachers who have left uh to go
to different fields because of the the
expense
uh the low salary
so compensation is important to retain
but we can only do so much because what
happens it has to come out of the
tuition rate so tuition goes up and the
and it's the parents who are now
struggling because now again it's
representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman
um thank you I'm just looking at sorry
about that
um the question is we're looking at a
complete a huge lack of supply and then
we're also looking at the low rates I'm
trying to understand as a business owner
how you're balancing increasing the
rates so that you can provide those that
available coverage for people who need
it while being able to to pay your
employees more but then also making sure
that it's not pricing out other people
in the market I'm just trying to
understand how you get to that because
I'm an economist I look at supply and
demand you balance the price with the
need and I'm just trying to make this
compute yes and again it's raising
tuition every time you know staff gets
increases so for September rate
increases are are expected and um and
it's not a low percent we give a dollar
an hour a raise every year to my staff
so if my staff has been with me for a
long time they're making more than they
are in other than other centers but it's
expensive
um to do that we are cutting back we're
raising tuition and maybe cutting back
on other things to accommodate that
thank you
other questions
thank you for taking my question and
thank you Mr chairman for giving me the
opportunity to ask uh the
when I when I hear all the numbers and
um
what keeps coming into my mind is you
know what in your mind is driving
the uh the salary rate the salary rates
up and what's
um and uh
which then
um
increases the amount that you have to
charge parents what factor do you
attribute that to
well we always look at of course the
minimum wage we are a mass a
Massachusetts Border Town
um my staff could go over the border and
make
substantially more than that
so that's always a struggle
and
raising tuition is our only only
yes
thank you again chairman McDonald
um
again I don't know if this is how it is
in New Hampshire but it's my
understanding that in many states in
order to become any sort of child care
provider or nanny or such you know you
have to get vaccinated with covid-19 do
we have any requirement in New Hampshire
to do that no we don't thank you
do you none okay thank you very much
also signed up to testify this morning
is Elizabeth brunette from the Applewood
remind people
I haven't said it for a while
thank you for having me
um this is my first time testifying so
bear with me you're welcome thank you
for being here my name is Elizabeth or
Libby brunette that's how I go I'm the
director of the Applewood Learning
Center in Londonderry and I wanted to
lend my support to this bill as a
veteran director in the field of early
childhood education I can tell you that
hiring qualified teachers has always
been a struggle but since the pandemic
it's nearly impossible
I have had two open positions
in full-time open positions with
benefits for over two years now and I
cannot fill them which results in me
shutting down a classroom of infants and
toddlers which could accommodate eight
children
now eight children doesn't seem like a
lot but when you have a waiting list of
approximately 80 children it's 10 so
we're talking about a significant number
that families that are not being served
because we cannot staff our programs
um
most of the time when a family misses
the opportunity to enroll when we have a
infant opening they're looking at a two
to three year weight on our waiting list
it's only until their child is preschool
age that they are then able to access
high quality child care
this potentially results in a parent
being out of work for about three years
our staff are in desperate need of
support we have teachers in our program
who are qualified to work in the public
school but because of their own
dedication to the field they have stayed
um
they're oftentimes only able to do this
because they have a spouse who makes an
adequate income they're living at home
with their parents as an adult or
they're taking on a second job which
oftentimes that second job
supplementing their meager income with
us is sometimes more than what their
hourly wages with us
these teachers are laying the foundation
for children's lives they're they're
learning their their way of being in the
world
um the groundwork we are developing is
um sorry contributing members of society
the national Forum on Early Childhood
policy and programs has found that high
quality Child Care is a four to nine
dollar return for every one dollar
invested so money spent in child care is
just smart spending thank you
thank you are you taking questions
any questions for this lady
uh yes representative palazzov
so talking about business decisions if
you have 80 people pretending for eight
sports like what stops you from
releasing a rates like is there concerns
that demand will develop
significantly in coming years or like
why why you're not just releasing the
rates to raise this a little thank you
why are we not raising the tuition rates
um so our tuition rates are probably the
I would say the second highest in our
town
um are for a full-time infant in our
care it's over 400 a week
um so families can't afford that they're
paying more for child care than they are
so we can't justify
I mean we can justify it's the actual
cost of quality but
will then end up with people going to
lesser quality programs
okay I see none thank you very much
also signed up to testify this morning
is Jackie Cowell from The Early Learning
good morning hi
I'm the executive director I'm Jackie
Cowell I'm the executive director of
early learning New Hampshire we are a
Statewide non-profit with membership
services for child care programs we do
cost buying and sharing and trying to
help them put money back into their into
their budgets we also do some of this
advocacy and on behalf of both of the
employers the child care programs the
teachers and the families they serve so
our mission if I didn't say it is that
we are committed to ensuring that every
New Hampshire child has the opportunity
to reach their full potential so I'll be
really brief because these are the other
these are the people you really need to
hear from most but I used to run for
about 13 years of child care in New
Hampshire so I
um and so what I'd like to say first you
know in addition you you heard well
about child care you know both supports
the workforce of today but really in
partnership with parents it helps
prepare the workforce of Tomorrow Too
something you may not realize the math
works on this is that a child who's
mommered at or both work nine to five
Monday through Friday can spend more
hours in child care than they will in
their Public School career all the way
through grade 12. the math works on that
and so and of course you all you
probably all know about the development
of the young child and now the brain
neural connections that are being made
this time of their life is so important
to have great experiences so that's
another thing that child care does in
addition to supporting the workforce
that people have mentioned very well
Senator excuse me representative Nagel
you mentioned you had a question about
turnover and what I can tell you is
not many
surveys have been done during the
pandemic it's all over the map and
people say it's not indicative but
before the pandemic and we know it's
worse now you've heard that it really is
worse now about 30 percent of the
workforce turned over
every year
so by three years you almost have a
whole new Workforce there yes there are
people who who stay and it's wonderful
that's what we're trying to do a little
bit with this bill
from my work with working with young
children in a Child Care Program I can
tell you we use the word turnover
but you ever go into one of those
classrooms and you hear the teacher
their three-year-old in front of the
three-year-olds telling them she's
leaving you don't call it turnover
pardon me you call it loss and we really
don't want this to keep happening in the
lives of young children and so what
we're really trying to do with this bill
is whatever we can do
um in addition to Band-Aid that's been
talked about I would call it a bridge
as the health and human services and
elderly Affairs committee I would love
for you to to on a policy level say we
support the idea of supporting the
workforce I tell you it's going to go a
long way to the field to hear that
you've done that let Finance figure out
that financing you know figuring out you
know where it's coming from whether it's
here or from there and
um and but I would love it if the Health
and Human Services is an elderly Affairs
committee would pass it along to finance
say why it's so important it will
honestly go a long way to the field
knowing you understand the work they're
doing and the teachers and that's all I
have to say thank you very much
I see oh yes representative palazzov
um uh do you know what the proportion of
tuition generally goes towards stuff the
latest as opposed to other business
expenses oh thank you I like that
question in fact about 80 percent 80 to
95 percent of of the tuition that comes
in whether it's sometimes the state pays
a portion for families whose incomes you
know but it no more money it's still 100
let's say it's 100 400 a week State
might pay this much the parent pays this
much if they qualify for this for the
state subsidy but the point that's that
tuition
um most whether non-profits and
privately owned almost all the money
goes towards Personnel it's a personal
heavy if you're doing it right right so
ninety percent of your 80 to 90 percent
of your expenses are people are the
people doing the work and 80 to 90
percent of your income is the tuition
that's where that this that's where
that's where people have talked about
why it's so hard the parents don't have
it you can charge it but you'll end up
with balanced dues and it doesn't help
the child and it doesn't help the family
and it doesn't help the program so we're
looking to see if there's any other
places besides the parents to try to do
something for the workforces
other questions representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
I'm really struggling with this bill for
a lot of reasons
um when I did the math it's about eight
million dollars am I correct over three
years
on the last page there's it's over the
three years it looks like the fiscal
note that came out yesterday was three
million in the first biennium 4 million
in the next and recurring I see and the
re the reason why I bring that up is
what you do is really important and I
really appreciate everything we're
trying to do but I want to make sure
that this is an effective Band-Aid got
it you're competing with virtually every
industry in the labor market and
virtually everybody's doing this and
everybody's ending up in pretty much the
same place they started with so why
would this be different to improve your
labor Mark your employability versus
others that you're competing against and
again you know the field obviously more
would likely help more
but and there are some bills you'll be
seeing them hopefully from the Senate
that actually do invest a little bit
more and more and annually however
you know if there's
honestly something really needs to be
said and and I do think it will have an
effect would more money have more effect
yes
but that's where I think Finance can get
into the details of it
um and um and you know I really thank
representative germana and Senator
Donovan for doing this effort to try to
start and and do some help
um I I really I I really want to say you
know it's going to go a long way
the messaging the saying it's important
that we're going to invest will make a
difference well I think and I think it's
a bridge it's a bridge to other
Solutions you know there's the select
committee on child care but they may not
have some you know solution-based
legislation perhaps till next year or
who knows the we need to do something
now to tell the field and I do think
it'll keep some of the talent there I
really do and that we really want to
keep the talent as much as we can and
the other thing with the empty
classrooms uh representative King you
mentioned about the home child care
programs and how difficult it is right
now and I don't have the number there's
been no formal survey of how many Child
Care classrooms are just empty right now
they have the electricity the heat the
toys the classroom they've got
everything except the staff
if we could do something there's
incentives here for new staff Etc we
might be able to start filling those
back up and that will have an effect too
thank you
other questions yes representative
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question I'm kind of following up on
what representative King asked um I know
he asked about the
the overall covid-19 vaccine mandate not
being a thing but is it a thing for
individual
um Child Care Learning yeah so have have
a lot of them made that decision to
leave the field you mean no yes exactly
yeah
um that's a good question let me just
okay they're better at this I haven't
heard it put it that way that it's made
a big difference in time
the difficulty of covet of closing
classrooms and not being able to get
paid and all those sorts of things
that's been tough but I don't think it's
about a masking so let me or vaccination
let me just ask yeah as the VAC has the
masking or vaccination been an issue in
losing staff I think at the beginning
maybe a little okay right okay sorry
yeah ah okay okay um but
um I think there have been quite a bit
of returns
you know there was sort of a panic and a
misunderstanding in the beginning of the
of the March April May
um in turn there have been some returns
but I don't have that stats but right
now the difficulty is simply
um uh if you know and the state is
trying to help with this that um parents
you know parents if the classroom has to
close but that's a whole separate you
know follow-up follow-up thank you so
are there still centers
implementing those mandates
there may be representative I don't know
it it's not often talked about or what's
what's talked about is the difficulty of
having to close a classroom down and
parents not being able to have child
care and staff not being able to get
paid if they've got it but not about
vaccinations or masking yeah
follow another one I do yeah sure yeah
so with that said that could be a real
issue for Staffing so has there been
conversations around
not closing down maybe you're not
dropping those to encourage people that
may have left and what to come back and
solve some of these Staffing Solutions
because yours isn't the only field we've
heard this in of course so and we're
trying to get of the root to the root of
a lot of these issues and I'll be honest
it's not a big talked about thing for a
reason to leave the field it's not a big
reason that people are talking about to
not come in honestly however
um they are following the CDC guidelines
as they are right now so yeah
hasn't it hasn't really been a big
discussion the inability to cover their
costs you know anything that can help
them meet their rent meet their as you
know any help is really what they're
what they're talking about the field
yeah okay thank you
representative Shapiro did you have a
question or oh okay
I see no other hand so thank you thank
you
also signed up to testify this morning
in a few minutes sir
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Will Stewart and I
am the executive director of stay work
play New Hampshire and we're a Statewide
non-profit whose mission is to attract
and retain more young people here in the
granite state and that's important um
just to lay the groundwork uh for a few
reasons one of which were the second
oldest average age in the country here
in New Hampshire have one of the lowest
unemployment rates and one of the
highest out migration rates of high
school seniors we need more people in
general here in New Hampshire we need
more young people in particular and
these are just some of the reasons that
stay work play is in support of this
bill and others this session that look
to support child care and the child care
Workforce in particular young people you
know here in New Hampshire you know are
needed not just as we've heard as
employees for our state's employers but
you know to serve an elected office at
the state and local level to serve local
non-profits to pass the plate church or
synagogue we need more people
and uh for young people here in New
Hampshire child care as we've heard is a
major issue and one of the reasons that
uh we don't maybe have as many kids and
one that you will encourage others to
leave the state among others you know
young people in New Hampshire face a
number of challenges uh some of which we
all face some of which are unique to
young people certainly you know we've
all seen housing costs you know
Skyrocket on the rental market in
particular which are disproportionately
occupied by young people we've seen
utility costs you know increasing which
affect us all young people in particular
are more burdened with student debt
having those payments and of course with
child care you know being young people
of child bearing age you know these all
kind of you know come together to create
really a perfect storm of challenges for
for living in New Hampshire and being
young and I'll leave you with this one
anecdote that you heard from a young
woman in the Upper Valley a few years
ago when we were out of making the
rounds you know talking to young people
in each region of the state about you
know what makes it a challenge you know
to live in their in their regions of the
state and what they like about it too
and as I mentioned this one young woman
was in the Upper Valley but I think the
comment applies to New Hampshire as a
whole she said you know the Upper Valley
is a wonderful place to raise a family
but it's a really terrible place to try
and start one and you know that comment
is one that's kind of stuck with me you
know these past two or three years and
you know really helps fuel me and our
organization to do everything we can to
make New Hampshire you know more
amenable for young people and easier to
live here and of course that includes
everything that we can do you know to
lower the cost of child care you know
for parents who don't um you're a little
bit more challenged and being able to
address those those price increases so
thank you for uh listening to me today
and happy to answer any questions anyone
might have okay questions
yes go ahead
thank you Mr chair uh just quickly
um in Your Capacity as executive
director of stay work play have you ever
looked at
um the retention rate on child care
workers in Massachusetts versus New
Hampshire and compensation in
Massachusetts versus New Hampshire have
you looked at those figures or do you
have access to them that's not a level
that we get into I would defer to uh you
know my colleagues who are you know more
um you know literally and figuratively
invested in the child care industry
Mr chair would a follow-up would it be
possible Ms Cowell raised her finger up
so she might have that answer would it
be okay if she answered that question
bulletin every time I have an article if
you come up to the microphone so we can
sure hi again Jackie Cowell from Early
Learning New Hampshire the New Hampshire
bulletin recently had an article by
Anne-Marie Timmons which uh mentioned
that in Massachusetts the average salary
or wage is about ten thousand dollars
more than those in New Hampshire Child
Care folks were earning in Maine I might
be mixing this up but I think in Maine
it's about 8 000 more 8 400 more and in
Vermont it was about 6 300 more maybe
not exactly right but six thousand eight
thousand ten thousand dollar difference
per year and I don't know the um
turnover sorry
thank you thank you
other questions
yes representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and also could you
follow up on they're paying the workers
more where's the additional money coming
from
I'm sorry I was I
go ahead sorry
you mentioned in other states Mass Maine
and Vermont the healthcare workers
making more in those States than here in
New Hampshire yeah so in order to
compensate them for the additional wages
where is the additional money coming
into the business of support is it
coming from the private Market from the
public market how is that being
sustained and maintained the bulk of the
money that goes into a child care
business to pay their staff is from
parent tuition yeah thank you
I'm seeing no other questions so I'm
sorry
go ahead representative uh thank you
chairman uh Mr Stewart uh thank you I I
you presented a lot of facts that I
thought sounded great but I'm wondering
if you could send the main bullets of
your oral testimony in writing somehow I
would be happy to do that yes
also signed up to testify this morning
good morning and thank you for having us
good morning
um so my name is Lynn Willette I have
been in the field of Early Childhood for
41 years now I am a director at a school
in Amherst New Hampshire called Nelly's
treehouse
I currently employ 15 employees
I need 19 employees I have had ads out
for months and months and months
sometimes we hire someone they accept a
position and they don't show up
um in doing this for 41 years our
primary goal is to make sure that the
children in our care
are loved and have consistency
so that they can learn appropriately
that is not happening now
it isn't covet that cause kovid started
the problem but it's always been a
problem but right now when I have an
employee who comes in and I say I can
offer you fifteen dollars an hour
Target down the street is offering them
20.
I can't raise my parents class anymore
and when I do raise their costs they
have to consider their housing their
electricity their food everything Rising
for them
my staff deserve to make a living wage
I work in the classroom because we don't
have staff
I have a wait list of 87 children
and on Monday because of my lack of
Staffing I had to call two parents and
say I'm really sorry but your children
can't start next Monday and I'm not sure
when they can start because I had a
staff member who left to go work at
Target
and I had a staff member who took a job
in a dental office
for far more than I could pay them
we need to help our families
New Hampshire is a family-oriented state
and our children deserve the best and if
we want to work forth we need to support
child care because we are that Workforce
behind that Workforce
are that the parent they called on
Monday cried
because she needs to go back to work
and I can't help her because I don't
um we talked I know that there were a
lot of questions about masking and covid
and
um we just stopped masking in September
for our staff
a lot of our staff have voluntarily
gotten all of their shots and we offered
a stipend for them to do that if they
did it
um but it's not the end-all be-all
a lot of our our staff are very
dedicated to what they do
um and if we don't stop and find a way
to get people into this field we won't
have a child care field in a few years
so we appreciate you taking the time to
listen to us
we appreciate anything you can do for
our field
um I know three thousand dollars seems
small but to some of my stuff that's a
huge huge benefit
um even if it's every five years
um so
we want to provide the students of New
Hampshire the children of New Hampshire
with quality consistent care so that
they can learn and grow we want to
provide New Hampshire with a consistent
quality Workforce
and we want to make sure that
we're doing everything that we can to
support our families here
without having to tell someone on the
phone hey I'm sorry I know you would do
to start Monday but
I can't take your child okay
um and she has nowhere to go
thank you very much you're welcome and
seeing no questions okay thank you very
much
also signed up to text uh to testify is
in a few minutes ma'am thank you hi I'm
Marianne barter I'm the executive
director at Merrimack Valley daycare
service in Concord and I'm the chair of
the New Hampshire Child Care advisory
Council I just wanted to testify because
I felt like I could explain a couple of
the questions that have come up
the first is that when I started in
child care 20 years ago 21 years ago I
was offered 11 an hour there are still
child care workers who are making 11 an
hour and that's because the economics of
child care does not allow salaries to
match the raising cost the rising costs
in New Hampshire it is expensive to live
here
our agency primarily works with
low-income families Children at Risk of
abuse and neglect and children with
special needs and I have never had a
person come to my office and say they
are leaving our Center because they
don't believe in our mission but I've
had plenty come and say they're leaving
our Center to work at Target and I find
the idea that people are passionate
about this field and passionate for this
work having to leave to work at Target
incredibly depressing and it impacts all
of us I am a non-profit agency so
unfortunately the tax rebate wouldn't
work for me but I think that that's
something that's absolutely worth
looking at to increase for-profit and
proprietary centers as a way to improve
increase their their financial
their Financial Resources I think that's
a great idea I did want to say that I
can't raise wages I mean I can't raise
salaries larger than they are I mean I'm
sorry excuse me I can't raise tuition
larger than it is because the bulk of my
families fall within that range of being
making too much money to get State
assistance but too little money to
really survive and thrive in New
Hampshire and I already give them a
sliding fee scale and I know for a lot
of those people they that Maxes them out
we also have a food pantry on site and
there's many many a time that I see the
families come and pay me their tuition
and then they visit our food pantry and
that is disgraceful and the eighth
richest state in New Hampshire in New
Hampshire I'm sorry in the United States
that is just unbelievable to me I also
wanted to mention that we remained open
during covid because so many of our
families are low income and frankly they
didn't have another option and because
so many of my colleagues had to close
that we really wanted a safe place for
children come in the Concord area while
the parents worked we also have a lot of
protective children so we felt like that
they needed a safe place to be while
their parents worked on their issues
during that time I never lost an
employee due to any coveted related
issues during that time afterwards I
never gained an employee because of
covert related issues we'd masked
sometimes we didn't mask other times
most people are probably vaccinated but
I don't ask
we're doing the best we can to serve our
families I will say that in child care
conversations I do not hear covid
restrictions coming up very often
so that's my testimony I hope that you
folks see this bill the same way we see
it which is a bridge to get us to the
next step I think in four or five years
Child Care New Hampshire is going to
look extraordinarily different there's
things in place and things that people
are starting to talk about at the
highest levels that will change the way
New Hampshire handles child care I think
that's amazing but we need to get there
with an experienced Workforce in order
to take advantage of these changes we're
going to have an entire generation of
children that do not have appropriate
Safe Care during the day
questions yes representative
thank you Mr chair for and thank you for
taking my question
um so there are educational Freedom
accounts available in New Hampshire
right now
um would any of the parents who utilize
your Learning Center Services have you
directed them to the use of those
accounts are they available for
preschool-aged children I mean they're
Learning Centers you said so I guess I
thought they were in lieu of Education a
regular school yeah so I wonder how that
like as a learning or if you're if
you're in a teaching environment versus
Child Care yeah I mean I think the
distinction between child care and and
public education that's always been sort
of a funny relationship we would have to
investigate that further I've certainly
never heard of anyone successfully using
the freedom care accounts I don't
[Music]
12 million dollars into their General
budget for supporting Child Care
Workforce and the way they do that is
that every month a child care provider
every individual teacher and provider
receives a 200 stipend
so um and that has increased retention
exponentially
other questions
seeing none I'm sorry representative
Weber
and would you be surprised to know that
for that extra two hundred dollars that
the main teachers are getting uh for 30
of that to go to the federal government
the teacher would have to be making more
than a hundred and seventy thousand
yes representative thank you just a
quick question can you please repeat
your name in your organization yes I'm
Miriam barter I'm the executive director
at Merrimack Valley daycare service and
I'm the chair of the New Hampshire Child
Care advisory Council
okay I don't see any so thank you very
much
and the last person signed up to testify
in this bill this morning is Sebastian
and I apologize if I mispronounced the
last name Fuentes you got it right oh
excellent okay I'm doing well thank you
Mr chairman and thank you members of the
committee uh once again my name is
Sebastian Fuentes I'm the movement
politics director for rice in democracy
of New Hampshire but I'm your most
importantly to kind of representing
myself I have four kids myself um two of
them are three and two years old uh the
only reason why I have this job and I'm
able to do this job is because my wife
has to work three shifts 12-hour shifts
overnight so uh somebody can take care
of our children and why is that it's
because we cannot afford the 640 a week
to take care for two two kids on a
daycare system so I'm here to in support
of this bill to see if you guys can
provide the right amount of support to
the child care workers that need it so
much another thing for 20 years of my
life I work in the hospitality industry
up in the North Country representative
King might be aware of Mount Washington
hotel is one of the largest employers up
there many times and I can count about
maybe 50 to 60 people that we
interviewed throughout 10 years that
have to leave the area or cannot take a
job because they cannot find Child Care
available in the area and whatever is
available is not affordable so whatever
you guys that this community can do to
help the child care workers in New
Hampshire that would be greatly
appreciated so that's all my testimony
uh I think many of them uh give the good
perspectives but I wanted to give the
another one as a parent of somebody that
has to struggle with this every single
week thank you so much thank you are you
taking questions sir absolutely yes are
I guess not thank you very much thank
okay I have no one else signed up to
testify is there anyone president who
okay seeing no one I am going to close
the public hearing on House Bill 566.
at this time it's just it's approaching
the lunch hour
um I
I know last week we skipped lunch but
we're doing much better today
so would anyone object if we uh recess
okay yes representative Weber could I
could I just ask what's happening with
574a are we going to hear that first
thing after the lunch hour we will yes
represent okay thank you
any other questions any other comments
okay we stand adjourned excuse me
foreign
we want to reconvene at this point
I am opening the public hearing on House
Bill 574.
first person I want to recognize in
terms of testifying is the prime sponsor
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee for hearing
I'm in strong support of this bill and
I'll give you a little bit of background
but I really have some experts here from
New Hampshire hunger Solutions in the
Department of Health and Human Services
that can get into the nitty-gritty but
what this bill does is provides an
opportunity for people women infants and
children to get fresh produce at their
local farmers markets
the coupons will be used
that they now use in existing grocery
stores
federal funds will support a hundred
percent of the food costs 70 percent of
the administrative cost
Bill appropriates three hundred thousand
for administration and enhancement of
the WIC Foundation providing an
additional thirty dollars in benefits to
be used at farmers markets
the state match will draw down federal
funds determined annually from the
federal budget Appropriations
and it will improve the awareness use of
and sales of farmers markets so not only
will it help those people
that have an economic need it will help
our Farmers have another Outlet
for product
why do we do this now farmers markets
infrastructure exists in the state to
support the program
there is an increased interest among
farmers and recipients in this program
the Department of Labor has just
reported that over six percent in food
costs have increased in the last 12
months
and allowing the federal nutrition
program participants to spend dollars at
farmers markets may be the only way to
increase market share for Farmers by
connecting them to new customers
I'd be happy to answer any questions but
I'm probably going to duck out and refer
to the experts behind you but if you do
have questions
I'll be happy to take representative
Leon um thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for being here and
holding over through lunch my question
is regarding the federal funds and if
you would be willing to have a sunset
provision that should the federal
funding go away this program also leaves
our statutes
I think I'm in favor of most legislation
having a sunset thing so yes I think we
would and just in speaking with the
people from the Department if there is
no uh
demand for this program they would be
willing to not apply for the federal
fronts and have it lapse too so it's a
two-way street thank you
other questions
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman also thank you
representative well for taking the
question
so basically this is going to support
our local farmers more than we have
today is that kind of the intent of it
to not only help recipients of whip WIC
if you will
to obtain fresh vegetables and fruits
and so forth but also to help support
our farming Community particularly them
many of them are small farmers that
thank you representative
um yes to me it's a win-win situation
people that are on the low income
Spectrum can get fresh produce locally
and our farmers can now provide for them
so
I don't know why this uh
seeing no other questions yes
representative
thank you
um so it's my understanding it says it's
re-establishing so this is restarting
something that existed previously
that's my understanding
it was it was in it
I believe it was a two-year program and
it did expire and now it's
yes go ahead
for chair
thank you for taking my question just
real quick um line six on the second
page it says the program shall
distribute food instruments
is that is that just food or what is
I'd have to ask the people that helped
okay
well yes representative Weber
could I ask that we finish with one
person's testimony before and if if
somebody has a question that needs to go
to somebody else that they'd be asked to
hold it because otherwise we have people
popping up and then popping down and we
get into conversations that are
confusing yeah so uh representative wolf
are you are you I apologize any other
questions for representative wolf
representative Merchant
thank you Mr and also Mr President of
wolf I see this as a non-lapsing account
and it goes until the end of
would it be opposed to making a
lapsing account versus an unlapsing
account so and give it a time of 2025 so
the funds have to be expended by that
period of time would you be opposed to
that versus it being a non-lapsing
I wouldn't be opposed to that
I think that's some of the things that
the Department's going to speak to
do you know other questions
okay thank you thank you thank you
and since she had already tried to come
up here once I'd like to recognize Lisa
cervoice from the New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human Services
Department of Public Health who continue
and we could keep your testimony to
three minutes that'd be great
thank you Mr chairman and committee
members my name is Lisa Royce bierschi
for population Health prior to this
position I have been the WIC director at
the division of Public Health for the
last six years so even in my new
position I still oversee this program so
just really quickly to lay the
foundation so the WIC nutrition program
is a 100 federally funded Public Health
Nutrition program for low-income infants
children pregnant and breastfeeding
women
our program is different than other food
access programs because we provide very
prescriptive Foods whole wheat bread
low-fat milk beans peanut butter infant
formula focused very much on
the period of pregnancy breastfeeding
and Child Development to get to healthy
outcomes
so the WIC Farmers Market program is an
add-on that is available for states that
participate in the WIC program
all 50 states participate there's
actually 89 programs across the country
because it's available for
Indian tribal councils and territories
the program in New Hampshire last
existed in 2011. it is a non-competitive
program that's available for States back
in 2011 the decision was made
to close the program because the
Redemption levels were low
and because of the state match
requirement was no longer available to
the program
so under this bill it would re-establish
the program although it still requires
permission from the United States
Department of Agriculture which we
submit a state plan to each year what
gives us permission and then gives us
some federal funding
however we can't draw down that federal
funds unless we can show that we have a
match piece the match piece is about 30
of the administrative grant that we
receive and just to put it in
perspective in federal 22 while we
didn't operate the program we sent in a
proposal to get permission to bring it
back to New Hampshire
we received a hundred and ten thousand
dollars for food
in about 23 000 for administrative costs
which would then require about a ten
thousand dollar State match in order to
operate
the federal money that is given to us
would only allow a ten dollar benefit to
be given to each child on the WIC
program which is about ten thousand kids
so you can see that going to a farmer's
market with only ten dollars for your
one child you maybe are going to get a
pint of blueberries or two pints of
strawberries so it's not as much of a
draw for families to travel to a
farmer's market and use the benefit so
under this bill this additional funding
the 300 000 per year
would give an additional 270 000 just to
the food benefit which would go directly
to our New Hampshire farmers
and then 30 000 to help with the
administrative costs
now within the last couple of weeks the
United States Department of Agriculture
has shared that there are modernization
grants available for states to try to
move the WIC Farmers Market program away
from this paper coupon system to an
electronic benefit system which could be
a QR code on your phone or a plastic
card which would help with redemptions
and allow Farmers to get paid a lot
faster
so the term food instrument is very
old-fashioned but it still exists in our
federal regulations it is generic enough
that it allows states to have paper
coupons checks through banking systems
or electronic benefits which could be a
plastic card or a QR code if you could
start wrapping up sure
um
so so under this bill this funding would
allow participants pregnant
breastfeeding low-income children up to
age five to visit a farmer's market for
a one-time benefit of thirty dollars so
the ten dollars from the federal money
and then the additional twenty dollars
from the the state appropriation
to be redeemed for fresh fruits and
vegetables at farmers market in the
intent of the WIC Farmers Market program
is exactly what was stated it is to help
low-income families access fresh fruits
and vegetables at farmers market and
equally to support our farming our
farming industry in this country
specifically for us here in New
Hampshire
and I'm available for any questions
thank you thank you representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for being here my question is if it's
possible to make any requests to the
federal government to allow this to be
in a more direct person to Farmer
relationship because I know that at
least some farmers markets have price
fixing and it's probably the most
expensive way to deliver fresh produce
to people and if there's some exemption
to allow a process other than a farmer's
market to get food from the farmers
directly to the families
yeah thank you for your question
um I'm not sure I exactly understand
what you're asking are you asking as
opposed to at the markets at like
grocery stores uh no I'm asking I'm
sorry if I can answer that if they have
a farm stand at the farm or some other
way that the farmers market their food
to the public if there's some other way
to do it without the added cost of
picking up the produce going to the
farmers market that then requires people
to get to that same place at the same
time and there's a lot of food waste
that's involved is there any way to get
a waiver to allow that to go to farm
stands or other ways where it can be
better integrated into the community to
lower costs and increase access yes so
under the federal WIC Farmers Market
program there are State options that
allow you to choose just markets Farm
stands stand-alone farmer locations so
it would give the department some
authority to make a decision what is the
best fit for our state in order to get
these benefits fits to our families
that's incredibly helpful thank you
you're welcome thank you other questions
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thank you
um you said the program died in 2011
sorry
um because of low Redemption
um
what was the reason for that and what's
changed do you think sure yeah good
question thank you so I wasn't in this
position in 2011 however I was still at
the department working under the program
it is my understanding that getting
those match dollars became more
difficult for the department and the
Redemption rates were around under 50
percent and so at that time they were
paper coupons that required families to
go to the markets and redeem them we
have seen over the past five years more
programs across the state move to an
e-solution more of a modernized version
of Farmers Market which has allowed the
Redemption rates to increase
significantly so we we feel pretty
confident that moving to a modern
version would really help those
Redemption rates
okay
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and also thank you
for taking the question
the one time is it like one time per
month one time per year can you
help clarify the one time what that
means sure thank you for that question I
I should have explained that better so
it is a one-time benefit for the
participant to be able to use be used
over the lifetime of the market season
so ideally participants would be issued
the benefit in June and they'd have
until October to redeem the benefit at
the end of October the benefit then
however expires it's no longer available
which is very much the way the WIC
program works you get food for one month
it expires there is no carry forward
representative Palazzo and I'll come
back over here thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question my
concern is
um if there will be a limit for healthy
food versus unhealthy food and
specifically my concern is uh you
mentioned low fat milk as a specifically
healthy choice so do you envision
putting some limitations on
participating Farmers if they provide
whole milk or if they provide butter or
eggs
thank you for your question so my
reference to the healthy foods is
specific to the WIC nutrition program
which is a separate benefit that
families receive participating in that
program WIC Farmers Market is solely for
fresh local produce fruits vegetables
some fresh cut herbs there is no
authorization for honey or baked goods
or milk or any other Foods maybe that
yes representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so just another quick one
another so would every farmer be
required to participate or is it opt-in
other questions
representative Weber
thank you and I I have a question for
clarification because you said in answer
to a question about is this just farmers
markets
um uh that it could be individual Farm
stands and it can also be used under the
federal program guidelines it could be
used at
I believe grocery stores as well I mean
we've had an iteration of this that
included both local produce grocery
stores and local produce other places
but would we not have to amend this bill
because the bill speaks
only to distribute food in instruments
to redeem for locally grown fruits
vegetables and herbs at authorized New
Hampshire's farmers markets so it
wouldn't be left to the department to
decide in that case would it unless we
revised the language here thank you for
your question and asking for that
clarification maybe I misspoke or when I
was asking representative Leon for
clarification
um it became confusing this program does
not allow the food instrument to be
redeemed at a grocery store okay it is
only markets Farm stands Farmers solely
to support the farming industry and and
may I have a follow-up follow-up but I'm
still left with the confusion
representative Leon's point if I
understood it was
uh it might be more effective to go
directly to a Farm Stand and although
that would be acceptable under the
federal program Would we not have to add
Farm stands into the language here for
it to be
authorized for Farm Stand use in New
Hampshire
there is availability under our
regulations that allow some of those
other opportunities and I I don't want
to beat a dead horse but we're executing
this bill tomorrow and if there is to if
there is need of an amendment we need to
get an amendment so my concern is if
what we're trying to do is include Farm
stands
this doesn't allow Farm Stand use
thank you thank you
representative cofult
can you can you speak a little bit to
the vendor authorization requirements
and process so my understanding is that
in order to accept
uh accept this as a form of payment that
a Farm Stand if that is added to the
bill
or an individual vendor at a farmer's
market
would be required to go through an
application process potentially even
have electronic equipment for accepting
electronic payment I'm not sure if that
would be required or not can you speak
to that process please sure thank you
for your question yes it is true farmers
that would want to participate in the
WIC Farmers Market program would have to
be authorized and there is a little bit
of a process a paper process and
typically an on-site visit including
civil rights training for example
requirements by USDA
um as far as I'm sorry I forget what the
second part of your question was
uh it pertained to any specialized
equipment that might be required for
accepting payment yes thank you for that
so we have heard from other states that
have already moved along in the
modernization process that farmers
aren't necessarily interested in having
little electronic devices at their
stands because most of them don't have
access to Wi-Fi so there is more
Innovative technology available such as
using smartphones for Farmers to be able
to move to an electronic version and so
that I guess that would be one of the
decisions that the farmer would have to
make for participation
other questions representative Merchant
following up thank you Mr chairman also
following up on President Cole fault's
question
to minimize the process to the farm
would be and so onerous potentially
when I shop at the local supermarket
there's times in which they actually
have produce out there it says Source
from a local farmer
would it be possible that within the
grocery store itself they're obtaining
the produce through the grocery store
from a local farmer to minimize the
farmer's requirement to apply for an
application in the electronic
would it be is that feasible under the
federal law to say that if the grocery
store can identify produce that's
actually raised locally and sold to the
store
the Federal Regulations know that would
not be an allowable activity
see none
okay also signed up to testify today is
Tiffany dotier from New Hampshire hunger
Solutions
you have three minutes ma'am
good afternoon chairman and members of
the committee thank you so much for
allowing me to speak to you today in our
support of HB 574 my name is Tiffany
dotier and I come to you on multiple
capacities today professionally as the
community engagement director for New
Hampshire hunger Solutions I represent
more than 300 of our partners Statewide
that are concerned and seek to improve
access to nutritious local food for all
people in New Hampshire I also come to
you as a dietitian to provide you with
evidence-based information about this
program and its Effectiveness in
improving Health as well as improving
consumption and and purchase of fruits
and vegetables I also come to you
personally as a woman pregnant with her
first child to talk to you about my own
feelings about how important farmers
markets will be in raising my own child
so first I want to talk to you about the
evidence for the program and so it is
shown that anybody attending a farmer's
market of course has
greater purchases of fresh fruits and
vegetables so specifically in the
populations of those that have low
income it actually is shown to increase
by their fruit and vegetable intake and
that's actual consumption by as many as
eight servings of vegetables per week
and two and a half servings of fruits
per week so really effective in that
sense and that's been shown in studies
across the United States it increases
specifically consumption of produce for
young children as well
that increased consumption as well it
continues two to six months after the
participation ends in that particular
program so it's it's there's that
suggests that this is a long-standing
change in behaviors that can actually
take place and change their actual
their actual desire for these Foods as
well
as a dietitian I know that it's really
important to expose our young children
to fresh fruits and vegetables at a
young age
to ensure that we establish good
relationships with fresh produce and
develop that desire and that taste for
fresh fruits and vegetables good habits
over a lifetime will reduce health care
costs and as well as good build good
purchasing habits and building Community
as well and being in community
as an expectant mother myself I look
forward to attending farmers markets if
anybody's ever been they're really
Lively they're really fun a lot of times
they have live music and other things to
look at people to speak to and it really
brings you into communities so this is
the opportunity for our children to
watch us in our communities having these
conversations with Farmers as well as
programs like these I believe will also
help people that believe that they can't
afford or are welcome in these
communities to be able to come to these
communities and so there's lots of
opportunities for learning for young
children to be able to both consume
fresh fruits and vegetables see where
they're grown see where they're produced
and not just think strawberries only
come from the supermarket and don't
actually grow out of the ground so
really really important additional
benefits it limits the way we spend
funds that are only on local produce and
go directly to Farmers and now is the
right time I'm speaking on behalf of
over 300 Partners across the state and
they are all behind us and they they
build local coalitions to be able to
support these programs and help get
information out about them as well so
this bill is a triple win both for the
economy for our people in New Hampshire
to improve health and as well as our
farmers and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you
questions
I see no questions
oh yes go ahead thank you chairman and
thank you for taking my question do we
know if farmers are interested in this
um Bill passing
um uh thank you for the question I do
know that we looked at this legislation
last year and we did have testimony last
year um the turnaround on this was a
little quick and we weren't able to
bring any Farmers I have her testimony
from farmers in the past that
participated in this program and saw it
as a huge detriment to lose it when it
see no other questions so thank you very
also signed up to testify is Eileen
you have three minutes ma'am
thank you
on the testimony of passing out is from
a colleague of mine who can't attend
because she's down in the education
committee hopefully the farm to school
bill is passing so we have more fresh
fruits and vegetables exposure to our
children and that's the main reason why
I'm here this is multifaceted in our
approach the New Hampshire food bank has
to increasing the exposure to New
Hampshire fresh fruits and vegetables to
our population
children learn what they live and when
they learn at a young age the
appreciation for fruits and vegetables
that's going to carry them throughout
their life and we know if they start
young they're going to lead a healthier
life
so our approach is multifaceted like I
said and this is one of them we also
operate Granite State Market match and
double up food bucks those are two snap
incentives so this is also a way I think
if a WIC participant is also a new snap
participant they could find out about
these incentives as well so there's more
incentives to bring them to the farmers
markets if they're also a snap recipient
which likely is happening if they're a
WIC recipient
so double up food box that operates in
the grocery stores to answer your
previous question it does not require
that the produce is local but they can
get double their snap value for produce
purchased in the retail environment
using Grant State Market match I mean
sorry double up food bucks
Grant State Market match operates the
same way but in the farmers markets and
at the farmer's stands so they are
equipped at the farm stands because of
these two incentive programs so it
should be relatively easy for them the
farmers to participate in this WIC
it's really about children learn what
they live I'll just tell you a quick
story when the New Hampshire National
Guard was with us at the food bank
during covid
I had an opportunity later years later
to run into Lieutenant Colonel Gagnon
and he stopped me and he said
you taught me something and I'm never
going to forget it and I asked him what
it was and he said I was expressing my
frustration to you
about people in the fast food line at
McDonald's loading up their grocery
carts with frozen pizzas why aren't they
giving their kids the food that they
need
and I said what if that's all they know
what if they grew up like that and they
didn't have that exposure they don't
know this is what you're giving them
that exposure for a healthy lifetime
so that this becomes a part of their
expectation in their diet
I deserve and I expect fresh fruits and
vegetables
that's what we're trying to do and this
is just one small part of it that we
hope you can support and any federal
program that helps feed our New
Hampshire food insecure we have 180 000
kids enrolled in school
12 of them are food insecure so that's
21 600 kids
we need to get to them as much as
possible and we're doing the best we can
and we hope you support us as well thank
you thank you
questions
yes representative Weber
I'm still trying to clarify about the
are available at farmers markets
Granite State Market match is available
at farmers markets double up food box is
available in the retail grocery stores
that participate okay so and so none of
those neither of those are direct Farm
Stand their Farmers Market programs
they're also redeemable at Farm stance
okay and are there participating Farm
stands oh yeah okay that is exactly what
I needed to know thank you
okay other questions yes
thank you Mr chair I'm not sure if this
is a question for you or someone someone
else but um what happens to the money if
I can't imagine it's not going to be
I think it would go back to the general
funds but that's I'm not the
other questions yes representative
cofult
yeah so you you said that there are
um already vendors participating in that
program so am I to understand that they
they would not need to re-qualify that
they would essentially automatically
already be able to serve as vendors I
can't say that only if the um
uh whoever they are set up with with
double up food bucks and Garden State
Market match made that you know kind of
like if you're on Medicaid you can
automatically get three and reduce lunch
we hope that passes as well
but you know the same type of thing if
that could be made very easy by the
department but that's not something that
we do
okay thank you
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um
I have a question about the dollar
amount
um the 30 that's per season correct is
that more I mean I'm thinking for the
consumer point of view is that more of a
symbolic dollar amount or will it have a
real nutritional change for that I think
it will have a real nutritional change I
think historically it was much lower and
you know 30 is a pretty good amount and
that's what I pay for my produce boxes
that I have coming out of a regional
Cooperative so I would imagine that they
would get probably given the percentages
probably
other questions representative Merchant
in the purpose thank you Mr chairman
also taking the question in the program
you're talking about
is there like in a farmer's market to
minimize the administrative burden to
the farmers
and also the technology can they work
together collectively so you have a
central place to pay for everything
versus every single farmer having to
have a license maybe it's not your
question maybe it goes back to the
department because if you got
10 or 12 farmers there that are selling
their produce and fruits and so forth
administratively having one central
place to pay things
would be a lot simpler for the person
paying it plus also for those who are
there I'm just trying to find a way to
minimize it in your program can you have
one application covering multiple
Farmers that they have to have their own
application their own software
but that's not a program that we run so
I can't answer that question
um there are Farm hubs that do that
collectively could a participant go to a
farm Hub and
that's that's a good question
um there might be somebody in the
audience that can answer that
but there there isn't a way
um and that would create
administratively you get a figure
somebody's got to be taking all these
transactions in and then paying them all
back out as opposed to the farmer just
getting it done right then and there
um I think administratively it might
cost a lot more than it alleviates
okay yes representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so I was taking notes
and I'm a little confused can you please
uh reiterate what the Granite State
Market match at Farm stands program is
and does and how it operates and how
that dovetails with what's on the
proposed bill so if you are a snap
recipient and you have twenty dollars
worth of snap
redeemable food food stamps
that money is matched in the farmer's
market so you can go to the farmer's
market and get another twenty dollars
and that can be spent there at the
same thing with double up food bucks but
in the retail environment for those that
participate
so doubles your buying power if you're
going to buy fruits and vegetables
I apologies how is that different from
what's proposed is it just that that's
WIC specifically or is there right this
would be Wick specific and the other one
is snap specific
other questions did you have your hand
up earlier okay I'm sorry other
questions
yeah I think that's it thank you very
and the last person signed up to testify
uh Morgan morani from the Seacoast eat
local uh eat vocal
okay
and we did receive her written testimony
that was just passed around so we
appreciate that anyone else uh wishes to
testify I have no one else signed up
saying not I am gonna I'm sorry
thank you for taking my question
um would it be in the interest of this
legislation to add the word farmers
markets in the end of line seven and the
my proposal representative was to on the
end of line eight
um
and online seven to add or Farm stands
after farmers markets which is already
in there
okay if that is acceptable to you or
even if it isn't I would I'm going to
get an amendment and bring it to the
committee the committee can do with it
what they please well my question to you
is would you like me to go downstairs
across the street and have ore Farmers
or Farm stands added in both of those
places if you would like to do that be
my guest I was going to go ahead and do
that but it doesn't matter I like you
and then you can bring It Forward
tomorrow to the country okay and
representative Merchant you had a
comment a comment if I may
um looking at the federal reg the
definition of farmers market does
include roadside stand
ah that may answer all of our questions
thank you
okay if it's already in there we don't
we're both off the hook we're both off
the hook thank you very much thank you
Mr chairman thank you representative
thank you
see no one else uh to testify on HB 574
I am going to close the public hearing
on this bill and move on
to HB 565. I am going to open the public
hearing on HP 565
and recognize the prime sponsor
thank you
honor roll colleagues for the record my
name is Megan Murray I represent the
towns of Amherst and Milford I come to
today speaking about postpartum Medicaid
expansion
HB 565 before you simply asks for an
extension one going from 60 days where
we already that we already provide
coverage under Medicaid supplemental
support to a full 12 months in benefits
post-pregnancy to those most vulnerable
and income and Circumstance
I'll cut to the chase funding has been
available and is already allocated at
the federal level all we have to do here
in New Hampshire is act
the bill is an effort to address what we
know and spoke to in data last term
regarding postpartum Medicaid expansion
uh whereby a small yet very important
population of those post-pregnancy are
left with a gap in coverage and frankly
access to care
I'm simply asking that we move the
coverage from 60 days to one year to
ensure that our Granite State moms and
babies have the best chance that they
can at an early at early intervention
and success it benefits us all
though I was lucky enough to have
insurance myself in all three of my
pregnancies and did not utilize Medicaid
I think about how many inequities exist
due lack of reimbursement or coverage
for those seeking and needing support
post-pregnant Tennessee throughout the
granite state I personally had a spinal
fluid leak in an epidural gonori that
resulted in months and months of
physical therapy and care my posture
today is a reminder of what went wrong
I was treated ultimately for postpartum
anxiety though I never knew it existed
more on that later
and so I didn't know what I was looking
for
um when I was at the doctors they would
often ask about the baby blues they
would often ask if I was sad or had all
of those sorts of feelings around that
but um
what I was never asked was about anxiety
due to what I experienced in
complications with the spinal fluid leak
a blood two blood patches to repair the
leak and a cellulitis infection
afterwards
now imagine that that same circumstance
where a mom uh and that was nine months
post-pregnancy that that was identified
now imagine that same circumstance where
new mom's 60-day postpartum Medicaid
coverage has run out what then where do
they turn or do they like every parent
trajon the best they can regardless of
their unmet needs there can be a myriad
of health issues experienced in the
weeks days and months after giving birth
whether it's needing a little bit of
extra support with lactation or support
and recovering from complications or any
other Rel need related to post-pregnancy
like mental health care
there are um
there are Inc income aside the issues
themselves don't discriminate and the
ability to access care
um
and the ability to access care is the
burden and early intervention lowers the
overall cost of care
studies show that investing early in
healthy mothers and babies yields
healthier communities and families I
think about roughly the Thousand
pregnancies in children whose lives
would be positively impacted should they
be able to receive an extended uh
term of care for a full interrupted one
year here in New Hampshire and know that
it's crucial to our success and theirs
so with that I'll happily take any
questions
got me in the middle of a of a sip here
thank you
any questions yes representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative and sorry if I missed
this and you already said it but
um how many states have taken this
option
that's a great question I think somebody
in the department who's probably
watching this at a closer level may have
a great snapshot of what other states
but I do know that it's moving forward
in many states across the country thank
you
other questions yes representative
Merchant
thank you Mr chairman also thank you for
taking the question
this is all predicated upon them still
being eligible for Medicaid so what
you know the 12 months you're talking
about correct the 60 days it's all
predicated upon a status correctly
through medical assistance only if they
qualify for the medical assistance in
the first place so after three months or
four months that they no longer
qualified does that terminate this
coverage
I believe that it is an extension of the
Medicaid so if they I and I'll let
somebody okay behind there speak more
more
um
I'm seeing no other questions so okay
next signed up to testify is Henry
lippman and Rebecca Ross from the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services
attending yourself to respond to the
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record Henry Littman
the state's Medicaid director the
departments in support of this
legislation
um some of you who are on this committee
last year may remember that you took
this up as well
I would like to uh I understand this
bill may also be being exec tomorrow is
that correct
I don't believe it is
they're all noticed but it doesn't mean
that we need to have a final disposition
on any of them tomorrow they can be
recessed
um the
um Consolidated Appropriations act at
the end of uh this past year that was
passed by Congress which also covered
the issue of the end of continuous
enrollment under Medicaid also made
permanent you may remember last session
possibly you didn't if you weren't
involved in it there was a five-year
window in which this extra fmap Federal
match was available this now makes it
permanent so I think just in the in the
bill updating the the citation to the
the current law on that would make sense
and I think that if if you need it for
tomorrow that could be easily
accommodated and then the second thing
is you may recall last session
the legislature enacted at 25 percent
increase in the rates for
hospitals delivering babies as well as
one
for our birthing centers so the
department I think in an updated fiscal
note would have instead of 200 000 would
have 300 000 to reflect that there was
that rate increase that occurred for
delivering babies subsequent to last
year's legislation
I'd be happy to answer any questions and
my colleague Rebecca Ross here can talk
about maybe the clinical aspects for
children and their moms Ms Ross would
you like to speak and then we can direct
questions to either one of you or
yes thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee for the record my name is
Rebecca Ross I'm the director of The
Bureau for children's Behavioral Health
we too are here in support as well as
the entire division of Behavioral Health
with regard to this bill it would be
um
critical to supporting the work that
we're doing with Early Childhood mental
health which we know focuses on the
parent and caregiver in order to ensure
the physical and mental health of that
parent or caregiver during the first
year to reduce exposure to Aces and
Trauma
and avoid a lot of what we're seeing
later in life so through the system of
care work we've increased the Early
Childhood infant mental health
programming and enhanced care
coordination and much of that work is
reliant on that parent or caregiver also
receiving the support and care that they
need during that critical time so we
support support the bill and and hope
that you support it as well thank you
questions
representative Weber
just would it be uh do you have that
citation with you now or is it something
you have to get for us and if so would
you be willing to
um either pass it up or or
I'm seeing nodding heads so uh Robert
Berry who uh thank you for your question
Robert Berry who's counsel for Medicaid
I think can look that up and provide
that to the committee thank you
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
um we have some questions around whether
this is a continuation of coverage
without an eligibility determination or
if this is only for eligible families so
could I ask that and then I'll follow up
since I think that was clarifying
representative Merchant's question
um thank you for the question
so an individual who is eligible for
Medicaid
ordinarily who's delivered a baby would
have six just 60 days more of coverage
to take care of their health care needs
typically what this would then do is
just extend that from 60 days to a year
so
they're under Medicaid for all
eligibility groups if you have a change
in circumstances you're supposed to
report that and that that could but
generally someone who remained eligible
would have that eligibility for the
whole period I think the estimate of
number of women that we had you know was
between
561 or so and 760 or so it's not a lot
of of in terms of the entire population
the Medicaid Program it's not a huge
number of people that's why the the
number to cover them is not not
otherwise because some people are able
to pick up coverage through other
sources either through the Medicaid
Program or outside of it
so in clarification then those 560 to
760 women those are women who were
eligible when they were pregnant they
lost eligibility around that 60 days so
oh sorry you guys were well ahead of
schedule uh so so okay so I see the
nodding head
um would these women otherwise be
eligible as a changing circumstance to
apply on the health Marketplace as well
to have access to continued care if they
fell into that Criterion and applied
um then they they would they would be
able to potentially access that but
there are if you think about someone who
is maybe taking a pregnancy leave they
may not have the income to to be able to
to qualify for another program
sorry and just the last follow-up if
they're on leave wouldn't they qualify
for continued Medicaid Eligibility
because they're not don't have income
um well that would
that would probably be true as well yes
thank you
other questions you've representative
Weber
well those questions lead me to ask for
clarification so now we understand if
somebody qualifies for Medicaid they get
60 days worth of postpartum benefits
services
so after the 60 days am I right in
thinking they still qualify for Medicaid
but they are simply not qualified to
receive specifically postpartum benefits
or have I gotten that backwards
it's not let me maybe
big eligibility okay so that eligibility
group has Medicaid coverage only till 60
days of postpartum and that's that's the
issue is that it's okay it's not General
Medicaid it's the eligibility group of
pregnant women so it's outside of the
economic guidelines for the traditional
medications okay thank you for
clarifying that
uh representative Nagel
I'm just um thank you for Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question
um why 12 months
um so generally Medicaid Eligibility
spans you have to redetermine your
eligibility every 12 months I think it's
just making it consistent with that uh
that you know we've had the exception to
that since March of 2020 because of the
federal public health emergency but all
individuals have to and that are in the
Medicaid Program have a 12-month span
again the only exception to that is if
there's a change in circumstance that
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question it says I'm trying to
you so up to 60 days they have coverage
yes with this they go to 12 months and
I'm trying to understand the Delta
between two months and 12 months as to
how many patients are have you been able
to figure out how many patients are
actually or postpartum women are
actually going to be impacted by this
that was when we were thank you for the
question when we were talking earlier
about the range because every year the
birth rate is different but I think we
generally would see a range about
between
560 to 760 based on historical
experience on an annual basis and again
that's why excuse me I think the fiscal
note in terms of what the cost is not
maybe as large as you might otherwise
think it might be but it's a relatively
small group of women who end up in this
situation but meaningful to that those
families
well and follow up just thank you in
some district is there a breakdown of
the needed services that occur from like
that two month to 12 I'm trying to
understand is it postpartum depression
is it whatever the other issues are do
you have do you have that data broken
down for that group of people we I mean
in terms of putting together the the
numbers for actuarially the diagnoses
that they come in with so things like
again if you think about making medical
appointments these days it's very hard
to get everything possibly done it may
be an infection it may be a cardiac
situation it may be diabetes those I
think are the common they're more
commonly medical or or mental health
could be substance use disorder too that
there'd be getting assistance with and
just getting that all done within 60
days is very hard to do
thank you other questions
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman it would be possible for you to
provide the committee with the
information about the eligibility
criteria for pregnant women and for
other people so that we can understand
what the differences are sure thank you
other questions
seeing no other questions
okay thank you very much I have the
citation if I can hand it to someone
thank you
foreign
also signed up to testify is uh Bob Dunn
representing the Roman Catholic bishop
good afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee
um it's good to be back in front of the
committee I'm Bob Dunn and I'm the
director of public policy for the Roman
Catholic Diocese of Manchester and on
behalf of Bishop abashi and the diocese
I'm here today to speak in support of HB
565.
I'm not sure if this got covered yet
today but the reason we're sitting here
is because of the committee of
conference last year just to sort of
refresh memory because the the policy
decision about extending postpartum
benefits to one year
um was approved by this committee and
then by the Full House and um and also
by the Senate but then it get wrapped up
in Committee of conference so this is
sort of bringing back a bill that I
think
um you know was was looked at it
provingly last year
um this is a a policy issue this
extension to one year as a policy issue
which is supported by Catholic Bishops
around the country as a pro-life measure
um and I think that it's pretty clear
that when you think about whether a bill
like this advances the common good that
it does and we always keep coming back
to the common good and human dignity
when we look at bills and that's not
just a religious thing but as you know
part one article one of the New
Hampshire Constitution says that that
government is instituted for the general
good
um and so um you know there were I the
family is the Keystone of our society
right we would all agree on that
regardless of our
um political perspectives or persuasion
and there's really few ways that we
could better support families than by
supporting and prioritizing the needs of
mothers and babies and
um I keep coming back when I think about
this bill to the fact that for those uh
you know relatively small number of
people that are being impacted by this
uh initiative
each one of the mothers
and each one of the the children that
are involved that benefit from this
legislation and from this law
um are is you know is one more mother
one more child that is undoubtedly going
to have a better future than would have
been the case otherwise
um so that's why we think this bill is
such a good idea and we'd ask you to
vote in favor thank you thank you
questions
any questions you see no questions okay
also signed up to speak today is a Nancy
Vaughn with the American Heart
Association
you have three minutes ma'am good
afternoon chairman McDonald
um Vice chair Leon and members of the of
the committee my name is Nancy Vaughn
and I am government relations director
for the American Heart Association here
in New Hampshire I have passed around
written testimony attached to that is
the American Heart association's fact
sheet on maternal Health which goes into
more detail than I will do in my
testimony today as to why we we support
this but we we do support this um this
policy
the American Heart Association
recognizes that this is a leading cause
of death for new moms in this country
tree one in three
postpartum pregnancy related deaths is
due to cardiovascular disease so it is a
policy that time has come to to pass and
and get this get this into law in New
Hampshire
the American Heart Association is
working in General on maternal health
issues women in heart disease is has
been a big issue we have been working on
for many years and with maternal
mortality rates as they are by working
on this issue we hope to improve the
cardiovascular health of women and
prevent death that that is happening so
Medicaid the Medicaid Program plays a
real important role in maternal health
and perinatal outcomes in time
postpartum visits which gets to some of
the questions that were just just asked
provides an opportunity to address
health issues that may not have been
known to the individual prior to her
pregnancy but but is now
and also any pregnancy related
complications that that have Arisen many
of these complications we don't see in
postpartum moms from like 41 days on out
to the the end of that that first year
and a little bit beyond even so that is
that is why the 12 months is something
that's very important to us it is a time
for having regular appointments if a
sudden appointment needs to be made
there's time for that wherein 60 days
you just don't have time for that for
conditions that we hope to get managed
treated overcome so that it does not
result in more serious illness down the
road particularly once they may find
themselves no longer insured then they
won't have access to health care except
for if they were paying out of pocket
for this or it comes down to hospitals
and health care providers having to give
unreimbursed care for these patients
so I'm not going to repeat what others
have said before if you do have any
questions
my email and phone number is on my my
testimony but I will take any questions
and hopefully be able to answer them for
you okay great
uh yes go ahead Chef King thank you
chairman McDonald thank you for being
here today
um thank you you weren't here earlier I
don't believe but we had we were
learning about another bill and uh which
had a topic similar to what you're
referring to and that is postpartum or
uh deaths within 12 months of more you
know maternal mortality and um one of
the witnesses
um testified that there's roughly 11
deaths annually
um
in the state of New Hampshire but she
also
um she also specified that those are
basically almost all drug related deaths
do you concur with that I believe that
there's
um also within that number is about five
maybe that were cardiovascular related
as well but yes in New Hampshire it
might be a little different than what
we're seeing in the rest of the country
and again I I just believe that
addressing substance abuse issues if if
that is what what the problem is is very
important
for that cardiovascular health as well
as as just saving their lives and
helping them go on to being moms to
their their children
other questions yes representative Weber
thank you and if you know
um
do you have any estimate
um comparing the number of cardiac
deaths with the number of people who
need treatment past 60 days who don't
die but who have conditions whether it
be heart cardiovascular whether it be
substance abuse whether it be diabetes
that still need required treatment right
um I don't have you know exact figures
on that but what we do say within the
materials that I had distributed is that
we believe so one in three we know die
from cardiovascular disease we believe
that two of those three deaths can be
prevented and so that would cover all of
see no other questions okay thank you
also signed up to speak today is Holly
good afternoon chairman members of the
committee my name is Holly Stevens and
I'm the director of public policy at
Nami New Hampshire the National Alliance
on Mental Illness Miami New Hampshire is
a non-profit Grassroots organization
whose mission is to improve the lives of
all people impacted by mental illness
and suicide through education support
and advocacy and I'm here today
representing Nami New Hampshire speaking
in support of house bill 565.
um the United States is the only
industrialized industrialized Nation
where maternal mortality is on the rise
um and there's an increasing number of
maternal deaths that are occurring in
the postpartum period
um data from the center of Disease
Control and prevention showed that about
one-third of all pregnancy related
deaths happen one week to one year after
pregnancy ends and getting to something
that one of the representatives
mentioned about you know data within New
Hampshire I couldn't find the 2022
annual report on maternal mortality so
I've got the 2021 report that has 2019
data in it but according to that report
half of the deaths there were eight of
them that year occurred in the six to 12
month range postpartum so it would have
occurred after this 60 days would have
ended if these folks were on Medicaid
and
um just to that point
four of those deaths were overdosed two
of them were suicide and two of them
were medical causes which is why Nami
New Hampshire has a strong interest in
this bill because a lot of the mortality
that happens with our women who are
postpartum is substance use and mental
health related
additionally one of the most prevalent
illnesses facing postpartum moms is
depression according to America's Health
rankings 11.2 percent
of New Hampshire women with a recent
live birth reported experiencing
depressive symptoms so I think that gets
to somebody's question about you know
data regarding some of these illnesses
so that's 11.1 percent of New Hampshire
moms are experiencing some sort of
we also know that the children of women
who experience postpartum depression are
affected research has demonstrated that
there's an association between
postpartum depression and delayed
cognitive and language development
disorganized or insecure attachment
higher rates of behavioral problems and
lower grades there's also a documented
link between postpartum depression and
the higher rates of depression in
children when they become teens
so for these reasons the the strong
mental health connection
um between
women who have just given birth and also
the connection to their children later
in life Nami New Hampshire strongly
supports this bill
great thank you very much uh questions
so is it fair for me to conclude that
whatever we spend now
on maternal and child health in that
first year is going to save us money
down the road
in terms of additional mental and
physical health issues it will save
money not only for the mom but for the
child as well thank you I don't have
return on investment figures but yes
last person who has signed up to testify
on this bill today Mackenzie Nicholson
good afternoon chairman McDonald members
of the committee thanks so much for
taking the time to hear my testimony
today I won't keep you too long I know
we've heard a lot today plus there's a
cute little baby in the room that we're
all going and going over
um so my name is Mackenzie Nicholson I'm
the senior director of moms Rising here
in New Hampshire an on the ground
Grassroots movement representing tens of
thousands of moms in the granite state
I want to share a little bit about my
story which is that when
um when I had my first child
those first few months we came home from
the hospital were some of the hardest of
my life
you know stresses with a colicky baby
who really didn't want to have any of
the formula that we had to give him not
to mention added Financial stress it was
a really hard time for me but luckily
for me I was covered by New Hampshire's
Medicaid Program we fit the eligibility
for criteria for the program and it was
hugely helpful
but pregnant people and birthing people
in New Hampshire are directly impacted
by Medicaid with one in four births in
the state being covered by Medicaid
women and birthing people to your
question representative often experience
a lot of pregnancy related complications
that extend beyond 60 days postpartum
including for things like hypertension
mental health struggles gestational
diabetes things like that that require
attention for longer than 60 days not to
mention getting an appointment
um our current state law only allows for
that 60 days of coverage
another very sad and you know scary fact
is that the United States is one of the
most dangerous places to give birth in
the developed world with major racial
disparities
especially affecting black women who
lose their lives at three to four times
the rate of white women and that's
separate from age economic background or
education and a recent CDC report that I
looked at actually showed that about 80
percent of those maternal deaths are
preventable
and that same report shows that 53
percent of maternity maternal related
deaths occurred between seven days and
one year postpartum
as a mom that struggled with my own
postpartum depression uh I I'm hopeful
that we are able to pass this extent
extended coverage in New Hampshire
looking back if I had known that we I
would have had access to continuous
continuous Health Care coverage I would
have been able to focus on recovering
from a C-section which is a major
surgery but instead I was thinking about
where am I going to find insurance
coverage if my employer doesn't offer it
and worrying about how are we going to
pay for those medical bills if they do
come up
um I was excited when the American
Rescue plan allowed for this extended
coverage to I know tell me about it
buddy
um
to answer another question there are 29
states in the country that have already
passed this extended coverage with five
others who are working on implementing
implementing the policy New Hampshire is
the only state in the Northeast that
isn't on that path already
um lastly last thing I'll say to you is
in a report for the Texas legislature
researchers showed that coverage that
was provided to postpartum women during
the pandemic benefited maternal health
so hugely that um women used twice as
many postpartum Services after that
60-day period between 2 and 10 times as
many preventative contraceptive and
mental and Behavioral Health Services
and 37 percent accessed 37 percent fewer
folks access Services related to short
interval pregnancies within that first
year
and the last couple weeks in the
Northeast has showed us that Devastation
can truly take place when there aren't
safeguards for moms in their postpartum
State and it's hitting close to home and
we I like my myself and many other moms
Rising members are not
um immune to those crippling effects of
postpartum depression so on behalf of
myself mom's Rising members we kindly
ask you to pass this bill and support
pregnant and postnatal moms okay thank
saying no questions
I know of no one else signed up to
testify does anyone else wish to testify
on this bill
that's bill 565.
seeing none I am going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 565 and
open the public hearing on House Bill
580. and to begin I would recognize the
prime sponsor representative haken
Phillips
foreign
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
members for the record my name is
representative Mary hacken Phillips I
represent Grafton County District 12
along with representative Murphy
um
which covers Hanover and lime
so I'm here to introduce HB 580
which would establish a children's
vision screening initiative within the
the reason why I'm here today before you
is because of the problem which is known
as
amblyopia which is a mouthful but it's
sometimes called the lazy eye disorder
and it is the most common cause of
vision loss in children and occurs in
about two to four percent of young
children ages somewhere between six
months and six years
this is about two out of every 100
Granite State children
with this disorder vision is impaired
due to abnormal development of the
neural connections between the brain and
the eye during early childhood
primary causes of this are misalignment
of the eyes and it's basically a
refractive error if you want to get into
the technical
um explanation I'm sure Dr Murphy could
um typically this vision loss affects
only one eye but
um people with amblyopia are nearly
three times more likely to develop this
Vision impairment and they're better
seeing eyes later in life so early
detection of amblyopia is critical this
treatment is the most successful when
initiated before the child reached seven
years of age
the battle to prevent this vision loss
due to amblyopia is a winnable battle as
many of our experts tell us and other
countries have definitely made strides
towards eradicating this vision loss as
well as other states in our country
without early treatment amblyopia cannot
lead to or it can lead to the permanent
vision loss in one or both of our eyes
um according to the experts that I've
spoken to in our state New Hampshire is
actually one of nine or ten states in
the country that does not have a
government-sponsored kids vision
screening program
I'm told that about 25 years ago the New
Hampshire advisory Council of vision
screening was established and it
reviewed childhood Vision screenings as
a public health concern
and historically there was a push to
screen children and their Vision at
daycare centers throughout the state
particularly in the North Country it was
an example I heard about but my
understanding is that since the covid-19
pandemic the public health efforts have
rightfully so been geared towards
fighting covid-19 and
um does
emphasis on Vision screens had declined
across the state
so amongst the reasons for declining
screenings beyond that public health
Focus being elsewhere is that you know
reimbursement rates here in the state
are pretty low and Healthcare
professionals time is extremely valuable
so when they're making those
cost-effective analysis about which
um
cases to take the screenings do not
reach that top of that priority list
so anyway I digress this bill proposes a
limited goal which is to improve
childhood vision screening numbers
across the state
so this bill is very limited in scope
and I'm intending to reach the goal of
increasing those vision screening
numbers
by just focusing on children ages zero
to six to have enrolled in the State
Medicaid Program
so we're not talking about all uninsured
and insured children even though that is
a lofty goal
we're narrowing down in ages zero to six
because screenings before kids enter
school is really critical because you
want to treat by age seven to reverse
the effects of this disorder
um and if treatment is not administered
by that age group obviously the
disability could become permanent so
we're talking a small window of time so
a specific year a group of children
we're limiting this initiative to
special screenings for kids that are not
reading at a grade level upon entering
the third grade
which is about the same age group that
we were just talking about
and also at the request of teachers
through a school administrator who you
know notice a lag in the reading skills
of a child
this is obviously intended to catch
vision problems that um become evident
after this initial screening for when
the student enters the school system
we're also limiting this initiative to
reimburse those healthcare providers who
are trained and approved by the
Department of Health and Human Services
which would include professional
pediatricians
Southern New Hampshire area health
education center who I understand
already participate in the State
Medicaid Program this section of the
bill is particularly modeled after
similar legislation on the books here in
New Hampshire that leaves the medical
experts to do this important work
this bill also limits
um the initiative only to a screening
which is a relatively inexpensive
process to have your pupils screened and
to identify a larger more serious
problem this bill does not include the
scope of a more comprehensive more
expensive eye exam
that is obviously an laudable goal as
well but it is not included here in in
this bill the thought is that if a
student would fail the screening they
would be referred for that full eye exam
later
with Healthcare professionals who can
follow
this bill also limits costs by paying
through title 19 Medicaid State Plan
amendments to CMS so being fiscally
responsible I think that this bill
follows along with New Hampshire's
strong tradition as being you know
very conservative with our dollars and
the important thing to know is that this
would be Federal funded and we're not
looking for State expenditures
finally this bill's reporting would be
to the state only through a parent's
form that they would receive at a
screening and then turn over to the
local school district
exemptions obviously are included for
religious reasons or if the child has
already received a full comprehensive
eye exam within the last 12 months or if
they've already received a diagnosis of
permanent vision loss
so the data will be gathered through the
commissioner of the health and human
services and then annually reported to
the Health and Human Service oversight
committee under RSA 126-a subsection 13
or colon 13 excuse me
this is similar to other childhood
initiatives data that's reported through
New Hampshire systems already
so there's no Grand depository no
registry we're not talking about some of
the privacy concerns that could go along
with the larger more comprehensive data
tracking device related to the screening
that is also not part of this bill
um so you know the important thing to
know about this is that I have spoken
with several stakeholders throughout the
state
including New Hampshire optometrists
Association which I believe their
lobbyist is here today
um as well as other new hampshire-based
optometrists ophthalmologists and
pediatricians
actually in fact some of the nation's
most leading experts on this issue live
in my district in Grafton 12 and I just
feel super lucky to have these experts
willing to donate their time and talents
to advance this cause
I think the main takeaways from my
meetings with the these groups are that
they agree the main goal should be
aligned to establish a low cost low-cost
vision screening Initiative for our
state
you know we've discussed several model
pieces of legislation throughout you
know New England and the Northeast as
gold standards that you know may be
replicable
here in New Hampshire but we were
recognize recognizing that the political
climate here in New Hampshire is unique
and that our model will have to be
different than what we've seen in other
places
so admittedly the goals of the nhoa and
the Physicians that I have spoken with
are much more robust than the initiative
you see here in draft form
you know they have three main goals
that um I see are missing from this bill
that one they'd like to close the gap
between a failed screen
and the referral and a completed
comprehensive eye exam so that missing
link is not included in this bill
which they would like to see the other
thing the second thing is that the group
would like to see reimbursement rates
for Medicaid increased as well and the
third main goal is that the group would
like to formalize some sort of database
um for tracking those failed screens and
how to follow up appropriately
um so again that's outside this build
I'm trying to keep it simple
but the largest arching concern I think
that was brought to my attention is if
you look on page one line eight and nine
as well on page two lines six and seven
there is a list of the healthcare
professionals that are listed
which are required under this law to to
complete the screening themselves so the
licensed optometrists physician PA or
advanced practice RN registered nurse
so my understanding is that through
conversations lay people such as School
nurses and other trained groups like The
Lions Club can actually administer the
screening
without requiring more like specially
medically trained professionals to
to conduct the same screening so the
recommendation would be for children who
have failed screenings to then be
referred to the this subset of groups
this optometrist Physicians specially
trained medical professionals for that
comprehensive eye exam follow-up
so um I think that this is an important
place for a possible Amendment if the
committee is open to that I know we have
wording that could be drafted quickly
for those two specific line items
and I understand that the stakeholders
that I've spoken with at the nhoa and
other Physicians groups
would prefer to amend this bill rather
than start with a you know fresh piece
of legislation
and I hope that the folks you'll hear
from after me today will share their
personal experiences with their children
screening
um
experiences uh
with you today as well So In Sum the
bill I think is a solid step for the
benefit of kids and vision in our state
and I'd just like to say let's not
forget that an ounce of prevention can
save us significant funds down the road
the more kids who are screened referred
and diagnosed early means the fewer
State resources down the road to assist
them in their communities and their
school systems
and I'm happy to request that amendment
I spoke about
um
so this bill could be considered for
ought to pass but if the committee
determines that more work is needed to
be done I know that nhoa and my
constituents would welcome the
committee's retention of this bill so
that further income input could be taken
in a you know more encompassing dialogue
could be undertaken to to really make
this bill something that we could be
proud of here in the state so with that
I'll take any questions you might have
okay thank you representative Leon
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative hackham Phillips Phillips
for coming and speaking today this is a
really important issue and it seems like
you got a really really comprehensive
big program into just a page and a half
which leaves a lot on local school
districts possibly a lot to rulemaking
Authority I'm glad to hear that you're
interested in retaining this because I
think that this this is going to require
a lot what do you think about offloading
this to the local school districts and
just the how that's going to cost them a
lot of time and personnel as well is
that something you would thought of yeah
thank you representative Leon for the
question
um so I think the emphasis on returning
reporting through the school system is
to respect the privacy of our
constituents you know when they're
getting their children screened
to really offload the professional
industry from collecting that data which
you know May at some point cause you
know eyebrows to lift you know of
children data being shared from
professional offices through a state
administrative body so I think you know
the common practice as I understand it
is that when children enter school now
anyway they're also returning some forms
about childhood vaccinations for
instance so
um the model of this legislation is to
provide a similar form for the screening
to just go through the same system
that's already established through that
initiative
um so I think while there will be some
administrative burden for local school
districts it's no more than what's
already existing in place for the
childhood vaccination situation thank
Sharon thank you for taking my question
um if if we were to be concerned as a I
am
um about screening and then you
understand that your child has a need
and you don't have the wherewithal to
provide for that need
um do you know if there is a similar
Medicaid State Plan Amendment available
to cover uh the actual
um eye examination and then treatment or
is that
or is is screening the only thing that's
available at the moment
thank you for the question
representative Weber um so in my
discussion with the folks um recently
from the nhoa it's my understanding that
um Medicaid reimbursements now include
coverage of comprehensive eye exams as
well as glasses
um for those follow-up referrals when
made the issue again that we were
speaking about is the gap between
actually receiving the screening and the
need for our follow-up comprehensive
exam
um and then getting those people to that
place and getting that exam completed I
think Medicaid reimbursements already
cover the possibility of paying out for
the additional
exam and glasses follow-up but you know
the issues we're just not getting all
the steps along the process so this is
one my proposed legislation is one way
to get the ball moving down the road
follow-up thank you so as a follow-up
this
does this completely close the gap if if
we get the screening and a child is
identified as needing either glasses
follow-up treatment of whatever kind
if they are Medicaid qualified they then
just get that so the issue right now is
that they're not being screened because
nobody's paying for screening is that
the issue so I think or is there another
step that I'm missing so representative
Weber you have identified the problem
um completely it's a multi
um
variable concern and multi-step response
and so yes we are there is a lag an
actual screening numbers so this bill is
getting at that concern but there is
also a lag between children who are
screened and referred for more
comprehensive eye exams because they're
failing the screening and then making it
to that exam and getting a diagnosis so
it's it's every point along the road you
see a fall off so I'm just trying to get
more kids pushed into the screening
system so that
um you know hopefully more parents
become aware and you know become engaged
with the process of moving down that
road to diagnosis and treatment
but they're still gonna yes there's
short answer is there is the gap okay
thank you representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and also thank you
for taking the question
this bill as I read it is really
targeted to Medicaid children
I don't think the disease that we're
talking about is restricted to them my
concern is how do we attack
the greater audience because
trying to identify children early on
with the issue is critical regardless of
the payment source so given the fact
that most schools have a school nurse
who I heard could possibly do this exam
it's a basic screening
could we not have a kindergarten or even
preschool have them perform the exam and
then at that point in time identify the
children who need to be refer to a
professional to do a comprehensive exam
and not have to burden the State
Medicaid system with the screening
process but taking care of what they
already take care of
uh thank you representative Merchant for
the question I think
um yes I think your inclination for a
more robust program Falls in line with
many of the state's optometrists and
ophthalmologists and Physicians
pediatricians wishes that you know every
kid would be screened coming into every
school situation but
um
that's not the scope of this bill
because we're trying my
the reality that I'm confronted with is
that I don't think there's political
will in our state to to reach that large
of a program at this moment in time
um so my targeting of this bill to just
the Medicaid
group of children it was because
I really think that these are the most
vulnerable kids in the system and um you
know
trying to help them and their families
through this process is you know a good
place to start but obviously School
nurses as you brought up are are totally
capable of providing those screening at
daycare centers or a young kid K5 type
Mr chair constitutions follow-up would
you believe my one of my young
granddaughters had something comparable
to this and was caught by the school
nurse through a visiting process we
could not understand why she was
following behind in her learning because
she couldn't see the chalkboard so
anyways make I want to say thank you for
bringing to our attention that's my
would you believe question okay a
representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I think the critical
thing to me personally is points of
access here I see three points of Access
One is zero to maybe age five which is
for you know kids that are in school
five and after for kids that are in
school and then probably early Child
Development programs for kids in the
middle
um my question is this I mean it's been
40 years since I did Primary Care
um but visual screening was part of
every well baby check Primary Care visit
and what I'm wondering about is are we
not already accessing that group if
we're not why not
um
and secondly if I'm seeing a Medicaid
kid
am I allowed to Bill extra now because
you're adding an extra fee to this thing
to all baby check
oh gosh um I do not have the technical
expertise to to give you the answer to
the question about a wellness baby check
and is there a separate like coding item
for instance
um related to a potential vision
screening
um so I apologize I can do some research
and get back to you with a follow-up on
that representative Nagel
um
yeah okay I want to say it's the first
part of your question though
um
it was I'm sorry could you please remind
me there were the three points of access
to care
um but school doesn't come until quite a
bit later so how do we hit these kids
earlier like if we're going to allow
personal things my sister was diagnosed
with ambly opioid Age Two she had
surgery at that age and you know she's
got perfect vision because of that um
that was she's now 70 years old yeah
um well that's a great success story so
um to to answer your question
my understanding is that um the
diagnosis can be
um
caught at many various stages of
children's development it may
um may not be caught at that first
wellness check or that you know the
two-year-old Wells truck but
um but that it could be caught later as
well I think that's why the third grade
reading level special screening
initiative was also thought of because
it could be kind of an after
um
the disorder could be developed later
than upon entry of school so I hope that
kind of answers the question about the
zero to six age group screening access
um the other thing I'd like to say
to your earlier question is that
um you know my understanding is that
pediatricians do a lot of these
screenings
um in their offices right now as primary
care physicians
for children and that
um you know that is one of the reasons
why the language that you see on page
one and two in those two lines came up
is because actually the first person to
bring this subject matter to my
attention was a pediatrician here in the
state of New Hampshire who administers a
lot of these screenings and has written
several
scholarly articles about you know this
exact issue so
um I think it is the work of Physicians
and offices as well as you know the
School nurses in our school system so I
mean there's plenty points of access of
course to to be
tapped I would say okay thank you other
questions
yes yeah thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question so can you
explain a little further what you mean
by I heard you say it before maybe
clarification on there isn't the
political will to have this done by
schools
what what do you mean by that oh so we
are very closely divided
uh legislature as you'll note
um so I I think um you know to have a
very robust system where we're asking
every school-aged child to to have a
completed screening you know whether
regardless if they're going to public
school or private school or you know
daycare centers
um I don't think that there's going to
be you know 400 out of 400 state
representatives who agree with that
program
um I would love that opportunity I just
don't think that's a real ass realistic
expectation for our house and then I
know the Senate chamber has their own
Dynamics so
um I just think that
that's a term we use in political
science political will is the likelihood
of a build going from concept into law
and you need the you need the motivation
behind the idea to get it through the
process I
by saying I don't believe there's a
political will to get it across is what
I'm trying to speculate that I don't
believe the largest program that will
benefit the most kids in our state with
you know the largest Medicare
reimbursement rates instead of Medicaid
you know I don't think that's possible
at this time so I'm really trying to
limit the scope to something that I
think is possible
thank you other questions
yes
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question just a quick point of
clarification as I as I read the bill I
thought for the zero to six that was
Medicaid eligible only but I thought
that the screenings upon entry and at
the third grade reading level that was
everybody not just Medicaid eligible am
I reading that writer I think you are
reading that right representative thank
you
uh yes
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um I'm wondering is this similar to the
system that exists or
hearing screening for children where
newborns are screened and then if they
need to they get then diagnosed by
someone who's more of a hearing
specialist and then they're if they're
under three uh put and sort of followed
and eligible for services through family
centered early supports and services or
through the doe if they're you know
three to six so I'm just wondering if
it's a similar
um
you know structure that where they
because if you screen children if you
screen people what are we going to do
about all the people who don't follow up
is what I'm wondering
thank you representative for the
question
um to be specific and to point of your
question I am not aware of the hearing
screening so I can't speak to the
similarity of the programs but um what I
can tell you is that this legislation is
modeled after a best practice out of
Massachusetts that has a really
comprehensive
much larger program and more robust
program than what I'm suggesting for
instance they do have the follow-up
mechanisms built in
um for the comprehensive eye exam
referrals and the follow-up that would
take place
including Data Tracking so um
again that is not what I'm proposing but
it is this is the first step of that
model legislation so that if political
will does increase in the future for a
more robust program we can build on this
starting point and try to
you know build that out that
infrastructure out okay thank you other
questions
seeing no other questions
also signed up to testify today is
come to you
um with a little bit of an anecdote
regarding
um some services that are provided with
regard to early intervention screening
within my um the district that I
represent both the towns of Amherst and
Milford have Lions Clubs and both of
them have recently acquired these
goggles of sorts that are early vision
screening they're quite expensive I had
learned
um and they're somewhere over uh 800 to
a thousand dollars per set of goggles
um and so through their charitable Works
they are having uh breakfast
opportunities for these kiddos free of
charge to be able to go and sit and have
uh the opportunity to get uh a screen so
to speak it is not something that is a
definitive medical diagnosis it is
something that simply says hey
something's not right here we would like
to flag for you that you should probably
get an additional
um doctor's appointment with an
optometrist or an ophthalmologist
there's no real um
indicator of what the issue might be
forward
we attended one such event when my
daughter was really really young she was
three years old and um
I had initially sent my son up there to
have the goggle screening he passed it
everything was fine my daughter at three
years old sat there and did the goggles
and she failed it and it ended up
catching a pretty severe astigmatism we
had noticed behavior before she was
we thought it was toddler related she
would trip occasionally depth perception
issues were a little bit
I would say more pronounced than her
brother and it turned out that she in
fact has a severe astigmatism that was
caught super early on and so while those
other organizations that do provide that
opportunity for such services like this
are out there
um it they are expensive to acquire and
so I think that this Early Intervention
Program is also crucial to making sure
that those who need the care and the
access to the care have it so like you
were representative Nagel were
mentioning points of Early Access I
think are crucial in whether it's
through non-profit organizations or
through a requirement for continued
screening to expand the Medicaid
services I I support the bill and the
intent of the bill I understand there
may be some work but I am happy to help
work on that with folks should you need
that well I'm happy to answer any
questions any questions representative
Murray
so you're none okay thank you very much
and the final folks signed up to testify
on House Bill 580 uh Henry lippman and
Rob Barry from the Department of Health
you've asked for five minutes anything
under that would be much appreciated I
know there's two of you though
I think we could do it in three okay
great thank you so I think the
suggestion to refer this for further
work
um
and to stay within the three-minute time
limit there are some issues that related
to who can build Medicaid in terms of
having to be qualified treatment
providers that would need to be sorted
out the list that's in there of the
professionals licensed by the office
office of professional licensure would
be qualified to bill there's also the
school setting that's been discussed we
do have a Medicaid school program in the
state it's run on an individual District
basis I do think that I personally
benefited from this issue myself as a
kid I was running into walls and my
parents trying to figure out what was
going on
so I you know we would be committed to
working with a work group on this to
figure out what is the solution or
Solutions in New Hampshire because
different school districts different
communities May based on their resources
have to approach it differently but I
think the the goal of this legislation
is the right and correct goal on the
personal experience can support that
I have nothing further to add in
interest of the of time
okay well thank you any questions for
none no wow Mr chairman um on the
earlier bill in terms of the pregnancy
related eligibility criteria emailed the
committee some information on that so
hopefully that answers that question
okay anyone else wishing to testify on
House Bill 580
I have no other cards no one else signed
up all right I am closing the public
hearing on House Bill 580 and I am
opening the public hearing on House Bill
282. I am going to recognize the prime
sponsor who is also a member of our
foreign
thank you Mr chair and thank you
colleagues for allowing me to introduce
House Bill 282 for the record I'm Joe
Shapiro representing Cheshire 16. Keen
Ward 2 Alstead Gilson Harrisville
Marlborough Marlo Nelson Roxbury
Stoddard and Sullivan took me a long
time to be able to say all of those
um
this is a simple Bill albeit a difficult
one to understand if you would just to
read the text it will increase health
care access to a small group of lawfully
residing New Hampshire residents
in 1996
the personal responsibility and work
opportunity reconciliation Act was
passed the federal act and this was
under President Clinton and this was
commonly referred to as the welfare
reform act and among other things it
um
created some obstacles to people
obtaining Federal benefits so in
particular to this bill it it created a
five-year waiting period for certain
lawfully residing immigrants before they
that's the bad news the good news is
that in 2009 the government created an
option for states to eliminate that
five-year wait for children and pregnant
women who are lawfully residing in the
U.S but not yet citizens
each of you should have a map in front
of you that indicates that New Hampshire
is the only state in the Northeast and
one of only 15 states for children and
17 States for pregnant women
this bill of pests will require New
Hampshire to amend its Medicaid State
plan to provide coverage for otherwise
eligible children and pregnant women and
when I mean other otherwise eligible it
means that they will have to be eligible
by income in order to um
qualify just like anybody else who gets
Medicaid
along with my testimony in the office
the aforementioned map you should also
have in front of you that July 20 2010
CMS guidance to States regarding this
option
among other things it lists various
immigration statuses that are considered
lawfully residing
while many categories are included the
largest number of affected people will
be those who have recently been granted
a green card
through family reunification
Asylum applicants and those on temporary
protected status
in addition victims of domestic violence
under the violence against women act and
those with a u Visa
which I just learned about
who are victims of serious crimes in our
corrupt cooperating with U.S law
it should be clear that this bill will
result in health care coverage for a
small number of lawfully residing New
Hampshire residents it does not apply to
undocumented immigrants
it does not even apply to DACA
recipients as they are excluded from the
federal Medicaid match
Professor Layton coo director of the
Center for Health policy research at
George Washington University using data
provided an estimate of utilization and
cost his estimates indicate that Health
Care would be provided to approximately
300 people at a cost of just over two
hundred thousand dollars per year in
the house bill 282 fiscal note reflects
us
to prenatal care and regular health care
for children is an important investment
in public health and will save money
through prevention And Timely diagnosis
lack of or delayed prenatal care is
associated with low birth weight and
multiple childhood medical conditions
when enacted this bill will reduce
uncompensated care for health care
this includes small rural hospitals that
struggle to maintain labor and delivery
services
Healthcare a federally qualified Health
Center in Manchester informed me that
last year they provided unreimbursed
care for approximately 250 children and
obstetrics children In Obstetrics
patients related to immigration status
at a cost of 150 to 200 thousand dollars
and you'll hear from some people who
will come and speak also about
um
efforts to re to obtain health care for
people who
um
would otherwise be eligible
um where Health Care Providers had to um
were thankfully willing to provide
while there would be a cost for easing
Medicaid and Chip eligibility the
federal government will pick up much of
it eliminating The Five-Year wait for
immigrant children and pregnant people
will send a clear message that we
welcome and value newcomers to our state
who enrich our communities and add to
our Workforce as employees and
entrepreneurs
so
um
I also wanted to point out now and maybe
we could save the discussion of this or
people could certainly ask questions of
this but about this but we can have a
discussion about it when we exec this
bill
the appropriation in the bill as is
written is a hundred and eighteen
thousand dollars and that is a product
of the bill that I
had written last year and that we
discussed last year and that was when
there was only six months left in the
fiscal year in the biennium coming up
so because it was so difficult to get
changes made through OLS at the very end
of the filing period that is not an
accurate amount the fiscal note of what
it will cost per year
which is 224 000 in state funds is
accurate but the amount that will be
needed for
the rest of the biennium which will now
be 18 months is I believe
336 thousand dollars and I have an
amendment that's
um written to
um
and I am certainly willing to take
questions
thank you yes representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
lawfully residing is that is that um the
criteria that you list in your statement
on paragraph five of the is that what
lawfully residing means those criteria
that are listed in that paragraph you
know having a green card or Asylum
applicant Etc is that lawfully residing
then
thank you for the question you should
have a pack in your packet of things is
um CMS guidelines on this option
do you do you have that I don't know I
haven't read it yet so okay
in that in those guidelines it lists a
number of categories of
immigrants that qualify under lawfully
residing I will be honest with you it's
um
even though I've put a lot of time in
this and I found an expert in Los
Angeles who knows this up and down it's
incredibly difficult to understand
um
so two points that I want to make about
I think we tend to have a very binary
view of immigration people are either
documented or they're undocumented and
that I've learned is not the case at all
there are
Many Many Shades of Gray probably
hundreds of Shades of Gray there are a
lot of people who are here
lawfully residing
um who are not citizens who are not
permanent residents yet
so that that
um guidance
explains all this and this is the these
are the these are the people who would
be the biggest beneficiaries in this
state
and I would say also about that and
maybe somebody from the Department of
Health and Human Services can respond to
this as well
that right now people apply for Medicaid
and they have to be determined to be
eligible or not and obviously the
biggest thing is by income
but they also have to decide whether the
state has to decide whether they're
eligible or not
who
um
who has this five-year waiting period so
the state through their district offices
and maybe with help from the central
office already makes these
determinations about these various
categories of immigrants and what they
will have to do is say well
now these people are not eligible
because they're on this five-year wait
and these same people if this law was to
be passed and it becomes statute now
these people are eligible
great thank you I do have that deep in
here somewhere
representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Shapiro for bringing this
back this year my question was about the
numbers that you gave from Amazon it
sounds like those numbers were pretty
close to what you had for the fiscal
note we're all was all of that in
compensated care related to Legal
immigrants or was that from out of a
larger issue in the Health Care system
yep
thank you for the question
um
my wife read this and she said she
thought that might be a little confusing
so those are those are not apples to
apples and oranges to oranges
um I think the point of that information
from the federally qualified Health
Center is just that they give a
tremendous amount of unreimbursed care
to people
who for various reasons do not qualify
for health care because of um
immigration status but they're not
necessarily the same people who would be
um
whose eligibility would change through
this law does that make sense that's
very helpful thank you
other questions yes representative
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question
um so I'm an immigrant myself and just
brought in my mother uh several years
back and
um she in that five-year waiting period
was eligible through the HealthCare
Marketplace to to have health care and
it was based on her income which was
nothing because you're not allowed to
work in those five years
so that monthly Marketplace Healthcare
was very very inexpensive for her during
those five years so wouldn't that still
be the case for
um who you are who was mentioned in this
bill
[Music]
I am certainly not an immigration lawyer
or expert but if I understand you
correctly you're saying that they
were involved in getting a green card or
had already gotten a green card
in process of getting process of yes
um
and and I have documentation of the
paperwork that she provided
you know to the marketplace to get that
and I know that there is an
international institute here in based in
New Hampshire that I believe dies people
you know through that process so does it
have to be
um you know expanding the Medicaid are
are they just not eligible or is is this
bill saying they're not eligible for
that Marketplace Health Care
not the marketplace Healthcare but my
understanding is that
um if they had just gotten their green
card and of course this only refers to
children and pregnant women
it's just a sliver of the people in
those situations
um that if they were children
or pregnant women
um
they would have a five-year wait before
they would become eligible for Medicaid
or chip
and if this bill were to pass and there
was to be a Medicaid amendment that that
would not be the case so I think that
it's correct that they could get other
insurance through the ACA but not
okay all set
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
so since a lot of states have already
done this uh where the five-year waiting
period has been removed what kind of
evidence do we have of the benefit from
either like a health or a health care
utilization or you know Improvement in
health outcomes or decreased in costs
because of not deferring care or all
these other reasons that would be the
reason you know the usual reasons for
why providing people Health Care
coverage is a benefit of not just to the
I don't have specific data about how
this change in those other states
has affected specific Health outcomes or
even people accessing accessing health
care I'm sure there is that data out
okay thank you
I see no other questions thank you
representative did you fill out a pink
card by the way we don't seem to have
one for you I collect all the pink cards
so I thought I didn't have to I don't
know but did you complete one no I will
okay also signed up to testify today is
you have three minutes sir
thank you Mr chairman I don't think I'll
need three minutes I'm one of the
co-sponsors on the bill and I appreciate
you giving me the time to speak today I
just want to reiterate what my friend
from Keane said uh about this
legislation I think there are a lot of
people here in this state who are in a
gray area not necessarily documented nor
undocumented and those people deserve
health care and if we give them that
health care we can help prevent
greater diseases or injuries that they
might get and having them to go having
them having to go to the emergency room
to which would be an even greater cost
to the state if we had just provided
this care to prevent those issues in the
first place to representative mazer's
point I think the marketplace there
would be a place for them in the
marketplace I think the the problem with
it is Medicaid and Chip the services
given by the public sector are by many
measures significantly better than
what's given on the marketplace for
lower income folks if you have there's a
number of examples and I'm no insurance
agent so I won't give out those examples
but there are a number of examples of
how Medicaid Doles out better Services
than the Private Industry can and I
think the people who would be eligible
based on this bill would be the people
who receive those services so I think
it's important that we protect them
under this legislation and make sure
that they're not left to the whims of
the marketplace which can itself be a
those are the points I wanted to make Mr
chairman I think that we have some
people in a gray area who need to be
covered I think the price that
representative Shapiro has brought forth
is
well established and would be worthwhile
for the state to incur to allow those
people to to be covered and make sure
that we prevent any other greater costs
from happening in the emergency room
later on so I thank you for your time
and urge the committee to pass this
legislation OTP thank you very much take
any questions if there are any any
questions
okay saying none thank you thank you Mr
chairman
okay I'd like to welcome back Henry
Lipman and Noah Barry from the
Department of Health and Human Services
good afternoon again for the record
Henry Lipman Medicaid director and we
will not take eight minutes
um
I guess
um just trying to fill in a little bit
of some of the testimony you've heard
from others
so I think in terms of the the benefit
to the state in terms of offering this
is
it begins with the presumption that the
person is Medicaid eligible except for
the time period the five-year waiting
period so if a woman receives prenatal
care the child gets well child care
visits if they in fact continue to
reside in New Hampshire and they're
healthy to begin with I think that's the
benefit that the Medicaid Program would
share from a perspective as to why to do
this
um uh back when this was introduced last
year the expert that representative
Shapiro who came up with that estimate
we also ran it by our actuary and we're
pretty close on our numbers so I think
the the numbers credible in terms of
what's for the uh
the updated number as you described it
representative Shapiro be happy to
answer any questions but I think you
know trying to stay within the three
minutes sure I appreciate that any
questions for these gentlemen yes
representative Weber
I just had one which is if you
it's a little outside your field but I
know you've done work in other places
other than our Medicaid Program
um is it it is true is it not that if
somebody shows up at our emergency room
with an urgent medical issue nobody
stops and finds out whether they're in a
gray area or the five-year look back
period they're just treated and then the
costs May simply devolve down onto
uncompensated care is that correct
I think it's correct and I just think if
you look at what the focus of this bill
it's a pregnancy right someone it's
going to happen and the issue is that
it's it's not if you will delayable like
maybe other chronic conditions and
things like that that's I think the the
cost to the system are guaranteed to
happen and they can be even worse if
they don't get the right prenatal care
you can end up in a situation where
we're
um
you know a neonatal situation and an ICU
where you know that they show up at a
center that does that because they
haven't received the right
prenatal care and care all along it's a
cost that gets built into the system
that we all pay for outside of Medicaid
as well
thank you other questions
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I just simple question do you
have any idea what percentage of these
people will eventually become citizens
of the United States
that I don't know
um I I would have just focused if you
sorry other questions
yes
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so I'm hearing this
right it's except for the fact that they
are here they have to wait five years
they are otherwise lawfully you know
um citizen or you know um uh present in
the United States and they qualify
otherwise for Medicaid that if they got
to that five years or they were not in
one of the qualifying categories they
would have Medicaid right now is that
okay thank you
I am seeing none okay thank you
he also signed up to speak today is Jane
Shapiro
from Project home representing project
home
thank you chairman McDonald and members
of the committee for allowing me to
speak to you this afternoon
I'm Jane Shapiro from Keene a resident
of Cheshire county for over 46 years and
I'm here in support of house bill 282.
last December the Kaiser Family
Foundation reported that in 2021 25 of
lawfully present immigrants were
uninsured compared to eight percent of
citizens and I think representative
Shapiro did an excellent and detailed
job of explaining what lawfully present
immigrants were and the fact that this
bill affects only pregnant and pregnant
women and children in that category
this is because lawfully present
immigrants more often work in jobs that
do not provide health benefits and
because they face eligibility
restrictions for public coverage
including Medicaid chip and Marketplace
coverage and I'd like to speak to the
question from the representative I'm
sorry mazur about Marketplace Insurance
because I have personal experience
trying to get some lawfully uh present
immigrants into that program and they
couldn't do it because they didn't have
social security numbers and I spent the
better part of an afternoon with them in
the office of Cheshire Medical Center's
designated person who does this every
day and enrolls people in that insurance
and the reason they didn't have a Social
Security number is because they hadn't
yet gotten the work authorization and
the work authorization took two years
and nine months to get even though they
had gone through all the documentation
and filed all the legal applications for
society Asylum with attorneys and
according to the letter of the law so
there as as representative Shapiro says
there are many Shades of Gray and the
people that I have worked with fell into
a different shade of gray than your
mother so I I have concern for them
um
since 2016 I have worked with lawfully
present asylis in the Keen area through
a program called project home New
Hampshire's five-year weight requirement
for Medicaid means that our local
providers and non-profit medical and
dental providers have had to decide
whether or not they will provide free
Care Dental Care is particularly
difficult to find fortunately our Health
Community stop stepped forward but it's
burdensome and there will be a limit to
what they can provide
let me put a face on those with whom
I've worked
a family of five who fled with the
clothes on their backs as they faced
life-threatening violence
the parents could not work here this is
the the person that I referred to
earlier until they received work permits
and Social Security numbers and that
took two years and nine months the mom
is now a housekeeper in a nursing home
and they've told me they really want to
clone her
the Dad is working to start his own
business
their children would be eligible for
Medicaid if House Bill 282 passes or two
teenagers who fled physical and
psychological abuse and poverty now Keen
High graduates one is thinking of
college and medical school and the other
wants to start her own business and is
working in her field of choice they
would be eligible for Medicaid if House
Bill 282 passes
or a young mom who arrived with a
newborn and two young children who now
works full-time at a local company has
her driver's license and a car her
children would be eligible for Medicaid
if House Bill 282 passes
or the pregnant mom with two young
children who just arrived like two weeks
ago if House Bill 282 passes they would
qualify for Medicaid after they have
been here 180 days instead of five years
and if we could start wrapping up please
yes these families have been fortunate
but many in our state have not because
they're fortunate because our community
has stepped forward and I urge you to do
whatever you can to ensure that we join
the other 35 States who have eliminated
the five-year wait period and I thank
you for your time and the extra time
thank you thank you questions
questions from Community yes
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh just to though
clarify on your response to
representative Mazda's comment when I
married my wife and brought her over as
an immigrant it took me 10 years to get
her work papers but she was able to get
an immigrant sorry uh
an individual taxation number which is
equivalent of a social security number
except that it does not allow you to
work and it was my understanding at
least in our case that we were able to
do everything with that ITN accepts
obviously work because that was that was
the condition of her uh Visa so I just
wanted to clarify that a bit thank you
for that comment and question I'm No
Authority but my I can only say that the
people that I have worked with fall
within the narrow category of Asylum
acai lease Asylum Seekers and so they
have they're all different categories
and different rules I don't know the
category under which your wife you know
fell but I do know that my experience
and I have talked directly with the
Social Security office in Keene and
worked very hard on this issue and I can
just speak from my experience I don't
know all the legal
um
citations that I can answer you more
officially
other questions
yes go ahead thank you Mr chair
um thanks again for taking my question
um so
because you referred uh back to me about
that so to kind of answer what you
mentioned to me about not having uh
Social Security didn't have that any of
that either so the only thing and so I
guess this is a question is
um is it not
right now permissible to submit an i
I-485 which is an application to
register permanent residence or adjust
status that's all that was needed to for
her for us to get health care I can't
answer that question I can just say that
the person who has given me the
information that I just shared with you
was the patient representative who does
this all the time and she uh she
actually got on the phone and called
several of her contacts in Concord as we
were trying to make this application and
the end result was you have everything
in place except the social security
number and therefore we can't process
your application
I can't answer it anymore specifically
I see no other questions
thank you very much Mr chair I'd just
like to point out that there is a
representative who passed in a pink card
and who has a little baby who's waiting
to testify so I don't they did pass in a
punk card
I'm sorry I didn't say it representative
toll okay
well thank you for pointing that out and
by the way have you done yours yet
foreign
ly to tell
okay
um
okay representative okay okay yes
representative toll if you'd like to
come forward and I apologize I didn't
realize that you're you're one of us so
thank you no need to apologize um thank
you so much
um honorable members of the Health and
Human Service committee I am here today
as a co-sponsor of the bill and just
really grateful to rep Shapiro for
bringing it forward and I'm here to be
in support of it Access to Health Care
is a critical need particularly for
pregnant people and children prenatal
care reduces the risk of pregnancy
complications for both the pregnant
person and the child both groups suffer
the consequences of a lack of Health
Care potentially for the rest of their
lives
currently immigrants some of them wait
five years to qualify for the federal
benefits that would make Health Care
accessible to them and New Hampshire is
the only state in the Northeast that has
not eliminated this five-year wait
access to prenatal care and health care
for children is not just an investment
in those who receive the care but also
an important Public Health investment
which will save money through both
prevention And Timely diagnosis
not only that but making health care
more available to folks in our
communities will let them know that we
welcome them and we value their presence
in our state
we know that immigrants enrich our
communities in many ways and this bill
affirms that
this bill is not just a health care
Justice bill it's also an immigrant
Justice Bill Health Care is a human
right and everyone deserves to be
treated with dignity and respect I urge
you to demonstrate your care for
children and their parents by voting in
favor of this legislation
there's one more thing I actually just
want to say that wasn't part of my
prepared speech I became like a new
mother to this one
eight weeks ago and
um
I cannot imagine how difficult it would
have been to not have access to care
while I was pregnant I got a terrible
case of pups
I got extremely anemic and needed iron
transfusions at our local hospital
and then when I had him even though I
was healthy and I have a lot of support
it's still a challenge I walked in and
got sworn in when he was a week old and
I could barely walk even though I was
smiling you know and you're tired and
this isn't the best of circumstances and
so I just really want to Advocate that
to this is compassion this is empathy
and as legislators there's no better way
to legislate than from a place of
empathy and compassion so I really urge
you to pass this thank you so much thank
seeing no questions okay thank you thank
you I'm sorry representative Weber
I'm I'm just looking at your fellow
testifier and wondering how much weight
he's gained over those last eight weeks
because he's enormous
he is um he he is um his dad's a gentle
giant um so
um a really big man so he must have
gotten his jeans he's doubled his weight
since um we were here so yeah thank you
so much thank you and I apologize for
the personal questions
it we cannot agree upon um we just have
to agree to disagree but one thing I
think we can all agree on is jordy's
pretty cute and um he deserves a little
bit of special we can't see his face but
we I'm for sure could we get a copy of
our written testimony please yes
okay
also signed up to testify today is
Richard Bernard from building community
thank you Mr chairman my name is Richard
Menard I'm the executive director of
building community in New Hampshire and
I should start I suppose by saying I too
am not an immigration attorney but I do
run a non-profit organization based in
Manchester that helps refugees
build successful prosperous and healthy
lives here in New Hampshire and I'm here
to support the bill uh
you're all correct that the immigration
system is very complicated I get emails
like once a week from Boston from The
Immigrant national federal office of the
immigration service changing various
groups statuses they go from temporary
protected status to humanitarian parolee
and on and on and it's complicated and
it's almost impossible to identify
particular groups who will have a
particular status for a long time
uh I can tell you that we are currently
working with people who came a year or
so ago from Afghanistan as humanitarian
Parolees and now uh people from Ukraine
who came as humanitarian Parolees and
both of those groups would be in this
five-year trap
now that this bill is about
had congress not specifically authorize
Medicaid for them
and I don't know who the next group of
people will be and whether Congress will
authorize Medicaid for them it appears
that Venezuelans now have access to
Asylum and and and all the Privileges of
other
documented legal immigrants in in the
United States whether they come to New
Hampshire or not who knows but if they
do I hope that the mothers have access
to prenatal care
and that their children have access to
Medicaid it's important for all the
reasons you've heard it saves certainly
saves money in the long term and having
healthy outcomes from pregnancies uh and
and I would only add that for New
Hampshire
having
uh
at a really strong and welcome community
of new Americans is enormously valuable
much of the work we do is to help
refugees find employment and we find
employers all over the state clamoring
for more people who can come work for
them the people we place are great
employees many are making eighteen
nineteen twenty dollars an hour
it's not the system that many people
have in their mind when they think about
immigration you know
trucks pulling up to corners and putting
in low day laborers that's not what's
happening in New Hampshire
people are here they're living they're
working really hard and they're in
important jobs in in manufacturing and
health care and everywhere else
and the need is great for more frankly
for our economy our well-being and the
to reduce that aging population that we
all worry about so I think this bill is
a is a step in the right direction for
creating a vibrant diverse community and
I think the the representative for
introducing it thank you I'm happy to
answer any questions thank you questions
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you to catch you at
the last moment um do you think that if
we do this this would actually be a draw
that would have more immigrants moving
to New Hampshire exactly I doubt people
will know enough about the state's
peculiar laws to come here because of it
but they might stay if they're here
because of it you know people leave
we just one an Afghan man who was uh
working uh at pitco just left for
California mostly because of family
reunification
this is actually a pretty difficult
state to live in if you're low income
and people leave virtually all of the
rohingya refugees have left Nashua for
example many of the most half of the
bhutanese have left conquered in
Manchester
and and I think that's a real loss to
the state having having a bill like this
is a way to say you know we value you
here we want to make sure you're well
and healthy and hope you stay
thank you other questions
I've yes
yes great
yeah and I just want to clarify because
I mean I think immigrants when they come
in should have options and it was a
little bit concerning to me to hear
testimony maybe those people on the low
end maybe their the Medicaid options the
root for them but for those that have
maybe a bit more means to find out that
the exchange is not an option
um has that been your experience as well
yeah
um I well what can I say um The Exchange
is really important
for most people their first recourse is
Medicaid for most of the refugees that
we see they start with Medicaid and
you're right as they get more settled
here and get more sophisticated about
how how the system works many do choose
to purchase their own insurance or they
may get it from from their employer
so Medicaid is not the only option but
it's it's certainly important for all
the all the reasons that we have it
representative Weber
I'm just wondering about a point of
clarification because it seems to me
like we're getting into comparing apples
and oranges territory here
um
if you know and if you may not be the
right person to ask and if not I'll go
and Bug somebody else later but
um
isn't this bill
aimed at Asylum Seekers who are in the
category of people who
may not work
because their status has not yet been
regularized to the point where they may
work as opposed to the people that I
heard you speak of who are working and
therefore have more options available to
them than those who are not allowed to
work
thank you for the question and also for
giving me an opt out my understanding is
that there that that the bill is open to
other people than Asylum Seekers and and
I'll let representative Shapiro explain
his research more fully okay but there
are people here who can work who are
Legally Legally Legally residing who are
not refugees with all the benefits that
come with that official status
uh and who also may not be seeking
Asylum
[Music]
also signed up to speak today is and I
again I may mispronounce the name so I
apologize if I do Hainan bedri from the
non-profit uh Public Health membership
Association
um
founded in 1992 we're leading trusted
New Hampshire Public Health voice that
empowers our members and communities to
achieve a healthier New Hampshire our
mission is to improve the New Hampshire
Public Health New Hampshire has over uh
the New Hampshire Public Health
Association has over 300 organization
and individual members that includes our
members to represent the Department of
Health and Human Services local Health
departments public health networks
hospitals federally qualified Health
Centers community-based organizations
Social Service organizations and many
more
I'm here today in support of House Bill
282 on behalf of over 300 Public Health
Organization individual Members New
Hampshire
and it's Public Health members aim to
improve New Hampshire's Health prevent
disease and reduce costs for all we
support House Bill 282 because it
invests in the Public's Health by
improving the health of the society
including those who are lawfully
residing in the United States the bill
also advances equity and fosters
economic resiliency the population in
New Hampshire is aging and Baby Boomers
are retiring 60 percent of our high
school seniors leaving New Hampshire to
enroll in colleges and others in other
states recent data show recent data have
shown a significant population turnover
in the state of New Hampshire we need
people who want to be doctors nurses
teachers and Engineers therefore we need
to invest in their health
especially those who are lawfully
residing in the U.S including temporary
protected status individuals Asylum
Seekers who have worked with who are who
have work permits and those under family
unification working on getting a green
card
uh we need everyone who's here to be
able to reach their potential therefore
we need to start by investing in their
health
they are part of New Hampshire's future
uh when we invest in them they will be
they will put their skills assets and
potential to work to make our
communities even better and healthier
and keep our economy growing
this bill will expand coverage will also
expand coverage to pregnant women and
children who are lawfully residing in
the United States the option to provide
Medicaid and Chip coverage to pregnant
women and children without without the
five-year requirement has been available
in other states since 2009.
New Hampshire is the only New England
state that has not implemented this
option 35 other states invest in
Children and Families by offering health
coverage options
passing House Bill 282 will improve the
health of all moms babies and families
on behalf of the association and its
members I ask for your support of House
Bill 282 and that you encourage your
colleagues to find the bill ought to
pass
hours and asyli and I was granted Asylum
back in 2005 so I know exactly what
people are going through kind of so I
support this bill very strongly great
thank you very much thank you any
questions
not seeing any questions so thank you
also signed up to testify is Bob Dunn
representing the Roman Catholic bishop
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I'm Bob Dunn Diocese of
Manchester we support the bill
everything I said earlier thank you
well that was quick
well this is a quick one
Nick
Jake Barry
next up is uh Jake Barry representing
good afternoon Mr chair honorable
members of the committee my name is Jake
Berry I'm the vice president of policy
of new Futures I'll try and keep this
brief Bob done as a tough act to follow
as many of you know new Futures is a
nonpartisan non-profit Health policy and
advocacy organization as new Futures
authorize kids count organization we
advocate for data driven policies that
support Granite State Children and
Families
as we've heard throughout this afternoon
legally residing immigrant families
often don't have access to the health
care they need because they're forced to
wait this five years to access Medicaid
and ship they're forced to rely on the
marketplace or other high cost insurance
Alternatives or to forego insurance
coverage entirely this negatively
impacts not just their current access to
needed health care but it can contribute
to higher poverty levels and other
adverse childhood experiences which are
known to impair children's brain
development and lead to negative Health
outcomes throughout the lifetime further
as representative Weber noted earlier
health care costs incurred by these
individuals can lead to higher rates of
uncompensated care which can put added
pressure across our Health Care system
and lead to higher premiums across the
board so investing these children and
families by eliminating The Five-Year
weight as proposed in this bill would
improve the physical and Financial
Health of these families and our state
as a whole and we ask you to vote this
bill out to pass and I'm happy to take
questions
okay thank you questions
any questions for this gentleman
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
and speaking to the exchange you spoke
to the price point but have you seen any
problems with people accessing the
exchange or has that been an option for
this community
I you know I I we don't work as directly
in this community as others here so I'm
not sure I can speak to that certainly
you know we are always concerned about
individuals uh who are not able to
access uh public health insurance or
employer-based health insurance and
their ability to access the exchange
both due to um price points and just the
overall um complexity of the system
um so you know we think that the uh you
know a public option like this is really
uh critical in terms especially for
individuals like this who are new to the
United States and new to the system
um offering this uh you know medicator
chip as sort of First Step health
coverage is really important thank you
saying no other questions so thank you
sir
I'm the final person signed up to
testify on this bill is a Nancy Pierpont
representing Sandra catch catcher
we're the Immigrant and Refugee support
group at the New Hampshire Conference
United Church of Christ
um becoming a member in 2012 and
chairing it from 2013 to 2022
could possibly answer many questions
even though I'm not an immigration
lawyer so I invite you to listen to this
letter very carefully and ask me any
questions you might want to after you
hear what Sandra now my good friend
once wanted to say to you
she couldn't be here because she was
called into work she works at a nursing
home she's a licensed nursing assistant
hello my name is Sandra nakanter a
Nigerian immigrant married with three
children two boys and a girl
I am writing to support HP 282 which
will allow pregnant immigrants and
minors to get health care
when I became pregnant in August of 2017
I was living in Dallas Texas
I was able to apply for a type of
medical insurance through the state
which is called Medicaid
it's like Medicaid
they that insurance covered both my
unborn child and me and included
postnatal visits as well
I was so relieved because I didn't have
to come up with six thousand dollars or
more for hospital bills
in November of that same year however my
husband was placed in immigrant
detention and transferred to Stratford
County Jail which is here in Dover New
Hampshire
that meant that my two boys and I needed
to come to live in New Hampshire
before we could make a decision to come
The Immigrant and refugee before we
could make a decision to come
The Immigrant and Refugee support group
at the New Hampshire Conference United
Church of Christ had to look for an
obstetrician that was willing to take
care of me and help me with the delivery
process
fortunately the group found Dr Perkins
Garrison Women's Health offered to
donate their services for my prenatal
and postnatal care because the state of
New Hampshire does not have any program
that covers pregnant immigrants
my boys who were three and nearly five
then couldn't get any medical insurance
through the state either
I'm very grateful for the help offered
to me and my family by The Immigrant
Refugee support group and Garrison
Women's Health
I recently learned that the reason they
needed to help me was that the state of
New Hampshire hasn't opted in to the
same Federal program that was available
my family was recently granted Asylum
during the week I earned my
certification to be a licensed nursing
assistant
now I work as an LNA because I love
helping people
I work in a nursing home and sing for my
patients to make them happy
I'm also taking classes at Great Bay so
I can become a registered nurse probably
in three years time
I hope that the state of New Hampshire
will opt into the federal program
more immigrant health workers like me
are needed in New Hampshire and having
this insurance available would be one
less obstacle to their coming
it's only by God's grace in the form of
the Immigrant and Refugee support group
and Garrison Women's Health Center that
does that conclude your testimony yeah
that's it great thank you perfect timing
any questions
representative King can I have a copy of
the letter from Sandra yes Cassandra
yeah you can have the copy of it just
thank you
I've heard a couple people talking about
the gray areas and as chair of that
group I I can I can testify there are
many gray areas one of them being an
administratively closed case
so there are people here who have gone
through the Asylum case got to the judge
and he said neither yes nor no but Sid
you can stay here you can work but I
don't think I want to put you on a path
to citizenship that's a gray area so
there are many many gray areas that
exist so if you if you're thinking it's
just this or that no
representative
Shapiro was exactly right there are tons
of gray areas okay thank you very much
any other questions from the committee
seeing none I have no other
cards filled out for people wishing to
speak today is there anyone in the
audience who does wish to speak on this
bill
house bill 282.
seeing none I am going to close the
public hearing from house bill 282.
we have no other bills noticed by public
hearing today so that concludes our
business today we will be reconvening
tomorrow afternoon at 1 pm here in this